Höchste Zeit für einen Blick hinter die Kulissen des Rasenfunks, eine eurer Lieblingssendungen in jedem Jahr. Frank und ich freuen uns darüber immer sehr, deswegen sind wir auch wieder beide hier, um eure Fragen zu beantworten, aber auch einige Ankündigungen zu machen. Denn wie immer eigentlich beim Rasenfunk tut sich ein bisschen was. Seid gespannt.
Rasenfunk? What the hell is Rasenfunk? Da lach ich mir doch einen Arsch ab.
Echt. Alles bla bla bla ist das doch. Alles bla bla bla ist das.
Das Tribünengespräch.
Er wird einfach nicht alt, dieser O-Ton. Oder dieser Jingle, diese O-Ton-Kombination. Frank, schön, dass du da bist.
Das stimmt, Max. Schön, dass ich da sein darf.
Warum gibt's diese Sendung jetzt erst im April und nicht wie sonst zum Jahreswechsel?
Keine Ahnung.
Na doch. Ich hab keine Ahnung. Vielleicht waren wir ein bisschen arg okkupiert und es wird vielleicht auch so ein roter Faden dieser Sendung werden, dass es insgesamt sehr sehr viel ist mit dem Rasenfunk aktuell und auch mit vielen Themen neben dem Rasenfunk.
Beim Rasenfunk ist viel los. Tatsächlich.
Aber wirklich, es fühlt sich ein bisschen an, als stünden wir mal wieder an so einer kleinen Weggabelung, wo wir wichtige Entscheidungen treffen müssen, so wie schon vor ein paar Jahren. Ja, aber genug des Teasens, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Wir kommen dazu. Wir haben heute im Groben zwei große Teile dieser Sendung. Und diesmal haben wir es auch so gemacht, dass die Fragen, die ihr uns gestellt habt, dass wir uns die beide schon vorher angeguckt haben. Also ist diesmal nicht so, dass Frank mir Fragen stellt, von denen ich noch nicht gelesen habe, weil wir uns gut vorbereiten wollten. Ich habe das bei Stay Forever, schätze ich das immer sehr, dass die bei ihren Feedback-Folgen so sehr komprimiert auch antworten. Ob wir das schaffen, weiß ich ehrlich gesagt nicht. Aber deswegen gibt es jetzt zwei große Teile dieser Sendung. Der erste große Teil, das ist das Housekeeping, wo wir euch auf den Stand bringen zu einigen Themen, die wir mitgebracht haben, in Anführungszeichen. Und der zweite große Teil, das sind die Hörerinnen-Fragen. Und da reagieren wir dann auf das, was ihr von uns wissen wolltet. Frank, wollen wir mit dem Housekeeping mal beginnen? Du hast gar keine andere Wahl, als Ja zu sagen.
Ja, wenn sich mein Blick zur Seite neigt, da ist mein Dokument, wundert euch nicht. Es geht um eigentlich das wichtigste Thema der letzten Wochen, das uns so ein bisschen, naja, aufgedrückt wurde, würde ich sagen. Kurz zum Hintergrund, für diejenigen, die es nicht mitbekommen haben. Wir haben, als wir die GmbH gegründet haben, mussten wir auch unsere Bank wechseln. Und haben uns auf die Suche gemacht. Und das große Problem bei Banken heutzutage ist oft, die Gebühren, die Banken für einzelne, auch eingehende Überweisungen nehmen. Und das ist logischerweise beim Rasenfunk ein Problempunkt, weil wir durch eure Spenden dankenswerterweise in der Regel eine Vielzahl kleiner Überweisungen bekommen. Das heißt, Überweisungen sind ein Kostenfaktor für uns. Und so mussten wir eine Bank finden, die da attraktive Konditionen anbietet. Wir sind bei Phinom gelandet, einem Fintech-Unternehmen, einer modernen Online-Bank, würde ich sagen, und sind da eigentlich ganz zufrieden. Das funktioniert alles gut. Die haben eben einen passenden Tarif für uns, der nicht ganz günstig ist, aber pauschal alle eingehenden Überweisungen enthält. Was für uns ganz wichtig ist, weil das ein sehr berechenbarer Kostenfaktor ist. Nun hat Phinom bisher mit der Solaris Bank zusammengearbeitet, die im Grunde so ein Dienstleister ist für Fintech-Unternehmen, ohne eigene Banklizenz und ist jetzt stark genug gewachsen, um sich eine eigene Banklizenz zu holen. Das bedeutet allerdings, alle Kunden bekommen neue I-Bahn-Nummern, bekommen wirklich neue Konten. Das hat man uns von Seiten Phenom eröffnet und hat uns großzügige 60 Tage gegeben, in denen die alten Konten noch funktionieren.
Du hast die Antwortszeichen bei großzügig vergessen, Frank.
Jaja, ich hätte tatsächlich die Air Quotes mitsprechen und mit zeigen können. 60 Tage sind leider viel zu wenig in unserem Fall. Und es gab auch auf Nachfrage keine Möglichkeit der Verlängerung. Ganz einfach, die beenden ihr Vertragsverhältnis mit Solaris im Hintergrund und können dann natürlich für einen kleinen Podcast, wie wir es sind, keine Ausnahme machen, leider. So, nun haben wir den Kontowechsel angestoßen. Das habt ihr hoffentlich alle, die diese Sendung hören, auch schon mitbekommen. Wenn nicht, wichtig, updated euren Dauerauftrag, schickt eure Zahlungen in Zukunft auf das neue Konto. Die Infos sind alle unter rasenfunk.de/kontobeziehungsweiseimforum. Dort könnt ihr auch die Fragen stellen, mitmachen.rasenfunk.de. Ja, jetzt ist es ziemlich genau einen Monat her, glaube ich. Am 26. März haben wir die Umstellung verkündet und quasi auch auf Finom-Seite gestartet, kurz vorher, so dass uns vom, ich weiß gar nicht mehr genau, 20. März, wann haben wir die Umstellung bei Finom gestartet, 60 Tage bleiben. Das heißt, gut 30 Tage haben wir rum. Jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, wie lief es bisher? Und Gott sei Dank und leider lief es wie erwartet, kann man glaube ich sagen.
Aber ein bisschen besser als erwartet, oder? Also man kann ja noch dazu sagen, weil das wissen ja die HörerInnen, die die bisherigen Folgen von uns beiden nicht gehört haben, noch nicht. Wir hatten ja schon mal einen Kontowechsel, als wir von Fidur zu Finom eben gewechselt sind, weil die für eine GmbH gar keinen Tarif hatten, der in Frage kam. Und im Nachhinein war es auch sehr gut, weil die Fidur Bank hat dann zugemacht. Also wir hatten dann ein ganz okayes Timing, sage ich. Jetzt mal mit unserem Wechsel. Und damals sind uns eben, obwohl wir mehrere Monate Übergangszeit hatten, ich glaube drei, vier Monate waren das, und wir unendlich viele 1-Cent-Überweisungen mit Hinweisen im Verwendungszweck verschickt haben, bitte, bitte überweist in Zukunft an eine andere IBAN, sind uns damals, jetzt habe ich die genauen Zahlen nicht mehr, aber rund 20, 30 % der Leute hops gegangen?
Ich meine, dass wir immer so von 20 % gesprochen haben, ja. Und tatsächlich ist das der Punkt, an dem wir im Moment sind. Also seit der Ankündigung und mit noch ein paar Tagen, naja, Übergangszeit, die wir schon mit einberechnet haben, sind ungefähr 20 % aller eingegangenen Zahlungen immer noch auf dem alten Konto gelandet, 80 % schon auf dem neuen. Also erst mal vielen Dank an alle, die da schnell reagiert und umgestellt haben. Super, super wertvoll. Das wissen wir natürlich sehr zu schätzen. Aber wir kämpfen jetzt für die nächsten verbleibenden 25 Tage oder wie viel es noch sind in der 60-Tage-Frist, darum die letzten 20 % noch zu erreichen. Jetzt ist die Frage, wie haben wir das überhaupt gemacht? Na ja, wir haben Newsletter an alle registrierten Supporter geschickt. Wenn ihr uns unterstützt und noch nicht registriert seid, geht bitte auf rasenfunk.de, registriert euch da. Wenn ihr dort registriert seid, dann bekommt ihr in solchen Fällen Mails von uns. Und außerdem schicken wir so ein, zwei Mal im Jahr eine Mail mit so einem kleinen Status Update für die Supporter. Ihr müsst keine Angst haben, da kommt nicht viel. Aber das ist eben unser Weg, direkt mit euch zu kommunizieren. Und im Grunde unsere einzige Chance. Nicht ganz die einzige. Die zweite ist ein Messaging Service, der auf SEPA beruht. Sprich, wir schicken euch Kurznachrichten in Form von Einsend-Überweisungen. Das haben wir gemacht. Wir haben, ich weiß nicht mal genau wie viel, aber so um die zweieinhalbtausend Einsend-Überweisungen rausgeschickt. Glücklicherweise funktioniert das bei Phenom sehr gut automatisierbar. Das war nämlich bei der damaligen Umstellung bei Fedormax Handarbeit.
Ja, mit eigener SMS-Tan für jede einzelne Überweisung. Und ich habe dann, da habe ich ja irgendwie mehrere tausend dieser Überweisungen gemacht und dann wurden wir irgendwann gesperrt, weil ich zu oft mir eine SMS-Tan zu schicken lassen.
Es ist Vogelwild. Bei Phenom geht es Gott sei Dank in Batches zu, ich glaube je 200 Überweisungen auf einmal. Das heißt, wir können die importieren. Vorbereiten mit einer CSV-Datei. Das war dann eben jetzt ein paar Mal mein Job, immer die eingehenden Zahlungen beider Konten zu vergleichen, des alten und des neuen Kontos und daraus dann diese Benachrichtigungszahlungen, würde ich sagen, zu generieren. Und ja, und das werden wir jetzt die nächsten Tage nochmal machen, um diejenigen, die jetzt noch aufs alte Konto überwiesen haben, an die Umstellung zu erinnern und nochmal darauf hinzuweisen. Und dann werden uns leider, aber wahrscheinlich trotzdem, immer noch einige durch die Lappen gehen, die vielleicht gar nicht mehr so aktiv reinhören. Man weiß es nicht, nicht so regelmäßig aufs Konto gucken. So eine einzelne Zahlung geht natürlich auf dem Konterauszug auch mal schnell unter. Aber ja, das ist im Grunde jetzt unser Weg, wie wir jetzt versuchen, die letzten 20 Prozent noch zu bekommen. Insofern auch vielen Dank an jeden, der seine Supportzahlung ein wenig erhöhen konnte, weil wir eben leider damit rechnen müssen, dass ich würde jetzt mal aus heutiger Sicht schätzen, 10 bis 15 Prozent uns mindestens verloren gehen. Wenn wir Pech haben, bleibt sogar bei den 20, die wir jetzt sehen. Das ist halt ein bisschen das Problem bei dem Weg, den wir hier gewählt haben.
Und dazu muss man noch sagen, wie es genau gelaufen sein wird, können wir eigentlich erst so richtig seriös in zwölf Monaten sagen. Denn wir wissen ja, dass es eben ein Prozentsatz von euch da draußen gibt. Und vielleicht ist er gar nicht so weit weg von 10 bis 15 Prozent der Leute, die einmal im Jahr überweisen. Das ist meist rund um Weihnachten, rund um Januar, aber auch rund um den Rasenfunk Royale ist auch so ein klassischer Zeitpunkt, wo wir mal so einmal Überweisungen bekommen. Und da ist es natürlich jetzt für uns nicht nachvollziehbar, kommt diese Überweisung jetzt dann trotzdem irgendwann und kommt sie aufs neue Konto? Oder ist das jemand, den wir jetzt verloren haben? Und die Leute sind ja dann drin in dieser anonymen Masse der 20 Prozent, die uns noch fehlen. Deswegen ist es auch für uns schwer zu kalkulieren und deswegen sind wir eben umso dankbarer, um jeden und jede, die es sehr schnell schon gemacht hat. Es ging dir ja auch so, gerade in den ersten Tagen, wenn wir das neue Konto abgerufen haben. Es war einfach schön zu sehen, dass da schon was passiert ist. Und eben auch, dass wirklich dann manche auch dem Hinweis gefolgt sind, dass sie sehr gerne erhöhen können, um das so ein bisschen abzufedern. Und dass das auch einige von euch gemacht haben. Und da kommen wir auch gleich nochmal in einem anderen Aspekt drauf, aber unterschätzt es nicht. Also was für euch quasi, wenn ihr um 5 Prozent erhöht, dann sind das bei der durchschnittlichen Spende, wären das 15 Cent Erhöhungen. Wir kriegen irgendwas um die drei Euro. Zumindest früher war das immer so grob der Durchschnitt. Das hört sich für euch absolut lachhaft an, aber bei uns kommt es dann eben doch in der Summe so an und würde dann eben einen riesigen Unterschied machen. Deswegen scheut euch auch nicht. Ich weiß, wir haben, wenn wir krumme Beträge bekommen, dann hat es immer mit den Gründungsdaten von Vereinen zu tun.
In 95 Prozent der Fälle mindestens, ja.
Genau, das sind dann immer die 19,04 Euro und so weiter. Das ist auch immer alles sehr schön. Aber scheut euch auch nicht davor, auch ruhig 4,37 Euro zu überweisen. Das macht tatsächlich einen Unterschied.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Genau, also das so als kleines Update. Wir, wir bleiben da dran und versuchen, euch zu erreichen. Aber ja, die, die ihr uns hier zuhört, ihr habt wahrscheinlich schon lang reagiert. Das ist jetzt ein bisschen preaching to the choir quasi. Aber ja, er weiß Bescheid. So läuft die Kontoumstellung. Ich würde unterm Strich sagen, es läuft gut, aber leider nicht viel besser als erwartet.
Und vielleicht hier noch der Hinweis, wenn ihr registriert seid als Supporter in, aber keine Mail von uns bekommen habt, dann schaut in euren Spam-Ordner. Die ist leider bei manchen im Spam gelandet. Da kann man auch nicht so wirklich was gegen machen. Die Kontoumstellung und die E-Mail, das ging alles raus Mitte März.
Ach ja, und da kommt noch ein Aspekt dazu, den wir zwar mittlerweile gefixt haben. Das weißt du noch gar nicht, Max. Aber wir hatten da ein technisches Problem, wenn ihr eure E-Mail Adresse in eurem Support Account geändert habt, wurde die nicht auf der E-Mail Liste geändert. Ach ja, stimmt. Das heißt, da könnte es sein, wenn ihr die in letzter Zeit geändert habt, dass es noch nicht aktuell ist, dass ihr deshalb die E-Mail nicht bekommen habt, dann meldet euch ansonsten gerne. Wir schicken euch gerne die E-Mail einfach noch mal zu und kontrollieren auch noch mal, dass es jetzt passt auf der E-Mail Liste. Genau.
Am 19. März ging unsere E-Mail an euch raus und da könnt ihr noch mal gerne nachgucken. Und das ist ein gutes Beispiel, was du gerade genannt hast, von so Dingen, an die wir einfach nicht gedacht haben beim Programmieren oder die wir nicht so auf dem Schirm hatten und die wir dann tatsächlich nur über Rückmeldung von euch erfahren. Also wenn irgendwas nicht funktioniert oder ihr das Gefühl habt, irgendwas stimmt hier nicht, dann meldet euch einfach bei uns. Es kann schon sein, wie in dem Fall, dass wir einfach nicht den Connex hergestellt haben, oder was heißt einfach, so trivial ist es ja gar nicht, zwischen quasi eurer Registrierung bei uns auf der Seite und dann eben dieser Mailing Liste. Aber gut zu hören, dass das gefixt ist, Frank.
Die Crux ist, wir haben uns irgendwann dafür entschieden, das Thema mit unserer Website völlig zu übertreiben. Und das holt uns jetzt hier und da mal ein bisschen ein.
Ja, vielleicht kommen wir da.
Manchmal beneidet man die anderen Podcasts, die einfach irgendwo auf einer Plattform eine ganz einfache, klassische Podcast Website haben und damit auch durchkommen. Aber wir wollten es halt immer schon ein bisschen anders haben und einfach so, wie wir es uns vorstellen.
Ja, und andererseits habe ich immer noch keinen anderen Podcast gesehen, Frank, der so viele unterschiedliche Feeds bedient und das trotzdem abgebildet bekommt auf einer Webseite, die nicht eigentlich fünf Subdomains hat. Und der Connex zum Forum. Der gefällt mir einfach sehr, sehr gut bei uns. Also ich finde das sehr interessant, wie sich das verändert, wie Rückmeldungen gegeben werden auf Podcasts mit Kommentaren bei Spotify und so weiter. Und das sehen wir alles nicht. Oder eben auch viel bei YouTube was passiert. Oder es gibt ja jetzt auch 390 haben irgendwie ihre WhatsApp-Gruppe, die total explodiert und die auch dahingehend wahrscheinlich sehr, sehr viel Sinn erfüllt. Aber mir gefällt das schon sehr gut, dass quasi wenn jemand bei uns im Forum schreibt, wir wissen dieser Kommentar geht nie verloren, egal was mit dieser Plattform passiert. Oder und das ist schon was. Also das ist schon sehr viel wert. Gerade wenn ich mir angucke, wie so manche andere Podcasts sich auch entwickelt haben.
Ja, definitiv.
Hast du schon die Folge, die 500 Folge von Geschichten aus der Geschichte gehört, Frank?
Nein, ich weiß, dass du drin vorkommst. Und sie liegt auf meiner Playlist relativ weit oben. Ich höre tatsächlich relativ wenig Podcasts im Moment.
Ja, es ist dramatisch. Aber du sollst sie natürlich nicht hören, weil ich drin vorkomme, sondern einfach weil es so interessant ist. Die sind ja ähnlich mit uns gestartet, kommen auch aus dieser independenten Welt. Und manche Probleme und Herausforderungen sind nahezu identisch zu unseren. Und manche sind aber komplett anders, weil es ja auch eine ganz andere Art von Podcast ist. Aber ich liebe diese Sendung und ich vermute das deswegen nämlich auch manche hier reinhören, die sonst gar nicht mehr den Rasenfunk hören, einfach weil sie wissen wollen, wie läuft es denn eigentlich bei denen. Was? Die gibt es noch? Hiermit seid ihr gegrüßt. Sind wir mit dem Kontowechselthema damit durch?
Ich glaube ja. Also hier nochmal der Hinweis, wenn ihr es noch nicht gemacht habt, guckt ins Forum, guckt auf rasenfunk.de/kontoundunterstütztunsweiterhin. Und vielen Dank an dieser Stelle, dass ihr es bisher getan habt.
Aber wirklich. Und das führt uns nämlich auch zum nächsten Punkt, weil ein großer Teil eurer Unterstützung, der geht ja in die Gästehonorare. Und die Gästehonorare sind ein Dauerbrennethema in diesen Rasenfunk hinter den Kulissen-Sendungen, weil wir, also erst mal die Einführung damals war ein sehr großer Schritt für uns. Die Umsetzung ist auch tatsächlich auch immer noch ein administrativer Aufwand. Also nicht nur, dass alle Gäste, die ein Honorar wollen, einen mitwirkenden Vertrag unterschreiben müssen, sondern wir erstellen dann für jeden Gast eine Honorar-Abrechnung. Die wird dann zugesandt, zeitgleich mit der Überweisung im besten Fall. Und das mache eben alles ich, weil ich da den Überblick habe und auch aus DSGVO-Gründen und so weiter und so fort sollte man da ja diesen Datensatz sehr wenigen nur zugänglich halten. Aber deswegen ist das ein großes Thema für uns und vor allem ja auch aus dem Aspekt, dass wir immer schon den Plan hatten, dass sich da was tut. Also dass wir mit Honoraren starten, die mehr oder weniger symbolisch sind, auch wenn es natürlich noch mehr ist als andere Podcastzahlen, aber immer noch nicht dem Aufwand angemessen. Und immer mal wieder wollten wir, wollten wir die Honorare erhöhen. Aber irgendwas hat immer dagegen gesprochen. Und ganz oft war es, dass wir aus irgendwelchen äußeren Umständen gerade gar nicht sagen konnten, wie viel Geld haben wir eigentlich gerade zusätzlich zur Verfügung, was wir verteilen könnten. Also das war einmal die Umstellung auf die GmbH, dann waren es irgendwelche Konto-Probleme, die wir hatten. Es hat auch oft mit so steuerlichen Gründen zu tun. Also mit der GmbH jetzt sowieso müssen wir eh nochmal ganz andere Steuern zahlen und Abgaben.
Ich glaube, es waren auch Corona-Auswirkungen damals.
Stimmt, ja, richtig.
Davon nicht vergessen, ist ja schon wieder fast graue Vergangenheit, Gott sei Dank. Aber war ja große Realität, weil wir auch nicht wussten, wie entwickelt sich der Rasenfunk in einer Zeit, wo kein Fußball gespielt wird, wo auch nicht klar war, wie entwickelt sich der Fußball überhaupt in Zukunft mit all den neuen Erkenntnissen. Es gab immer gewisse Unsicherheiten, weil so ein Honorarsatz haben wir immer gesagt, wir wollen das jetzt auch nicht jeden Monat ändern oder plötzlich wieder nach unten anpassen müssen, sondern es soll auch eine gewisse Stabilität und eine gewisse Berechenbarkeit haben. Und so sehr wir eure Unterstützung schätzen, so unberechenbar war sie aber auch oft für uns, weil halt eben nie klar war, wer springt jetzt ab, weil es ihm persönlich schlechter geht in einer Zeit, in der es vielen schlechter geht oder weil der Fußball an Beliebtheit abnimmt oder keine Ahnung, all diese Faktoren waren so ein bisschen immer ein Punkt. Vor allem, weil unsere angedachten Sprünge eigentlich auch immer ein bisschen größer waren. Also wir hatten nie überlegt, wir gehen jetzt von 30 auf 32 Euro in diesen Dimensionen. Sondern es war immer so, dass dadurch, dass es eine Weile nicht passiert ist, wir gedacht haben, naja, wir müssten jetzt eigentlich mal wieder einen Sprung machen. Und umso größer dieser Sprung ist, umso schwerer ist natürlich die Entscheidung und die wirtschaftliche Machbarkeit.
Plus dazu sind unsere Honorarausgaben, ich nenne auch gleich noch die Zahlen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, sind kontinuierlich gestiegen, weil unser Output und unsere Gästezahl einfach gestiegen ist oder die Anzahl der Auftritte. Also ich sage euch mal kurz, wie bisher die Regelung war. Wir hatten immer schon feste Sätze. Früher, als wir damit angefangen haben, es müsste 2018 gewesen sein, waren es zwischen 30 und 100 Euro. Das war damals noch abhängig vom Format. Inzwischen sind es zwischen 50 und 150 Euro abhängig vom Aufwand. Ich möchte aber betonen, wir sind deutlich öfter bei den 50 und ganz, ganz selten bei den 150. Also das ist das, was ich meine, wenn ich sage, es ist dann doch noch eher symbolisch, weil da guckt jemand fünf Bundesligaspiele und kriegt 50 Euro dafür. Die ModeratorInnen, die mich vertreten, bekommen logischerweise mehr. Das ist meist zwischen 100 und 200 Euro. Und es gibt auch Ausnahmen von Gästen, die kein Honorar bekommen. Also zum einen natürlich gibt es Gäste, die darauf verzichten. Es gibt auch Gäste, die sagen, spendet es gerne entweder an eine Institution, die sie vorschlagen. Manchmal überlassen sie das uns auch. Das kommt auch immer wieder vor. Und wir hatten uns damals die Regel gegeben, wenn jemand etwas bewirbt und das Gespräch über einen Dritten, wie zum Beispiel in der Agentur zustande kommt, dass wir dann keinen Honorar zahlen wollen, weil wir nicht den Eindruck entstehen lassen wollen, wir hätten jetzt, also jemand hätte sich quasi ja oder wir hätten jemanden bezahlt, ein Gesprächspartner erkauft. Das wären ja dann öfter prominentere Gesprächspartner innen. Inzwischen muss ich aber sagen, irgendwie ist diese Regel ein bisschen komisch, weil kommt das eigentlich fast nie vor oder ist, glaube ich, noch nie vorgekommen, wenn ich jetzt so drüber nachdenke. Und ich tendiere inzwischen dazu zu sagen, na ja, wenn wir auf jemanden zugehen oder wenn wir einen Vorschlag bekommen, wo wir sagen, das ist den Aufwand ja auch der Vorbereitung wert, dann wäre vielleicht auch eine Aufwandsentschädigung nicht so, dass man da ein schlechtes Gefühl haben müsste. Also da waren wir vielleicht wieder ein bisschen.
Und außerdem, also die Grundregel, der ist ja, hat ja den richtigen Geist, glaube ich. Aber der Punkt ist ja, wenn jetzt, und das kommt oft vor, wenn jetzt Verlag XY zu uns kommt und sagt, hier unser Autor Hans Dampf hat hier ein ganz tolles Buch geschrieben, wollte er den nicht einladen, dann machen wir das natürlich ohnehin nur, wenn wir das in irgendeiner Form für interessant halten. Wir sind in der Regel keine Werbeplattform, es sei denn jetzt zum Beispiel für befreundete Podcaster aus München, die interessante Magazine auf Papier veröffentlichen, um keinen Namen zu nennen. Servus. Grüß dich. Aber ansonsten bieten wir da ohnehin keine Plattformen, wenn wir nicht inhaltlich überzeugt sind. Insofern glaube ich, ist es in der Tat eine überflüssige Regel.
Ja, da waren wir einfach mal wieder ein bisschen streng, aber wir wollten halt mögliche Kritik zuvorkommen. Das ist ja eh so ein Ding, dass wir uns immer schon den Kopf machen, wie kommt etwas außerhalb an? Aber das ist eben aktuell die Regel. Und jetzt noch kurz, damit ihr quasi, also zwischen 50 und 150 Euro, aber wie gesagt, geht einfach mal von den 50 aus. Das ist das, was wir am aller, aller häufigsten überweisen. Manchmal mit Umsatzsteuer, manchmal ohne. Dafür braucht es auch einen mitwirkenden Vertrag übrigens. Und ich möchte herzlich unseren zuständigen Betriebsprüfer gerade im Finanzamt München grüßen an dieser Stelle. Ich weiß, es ist alles ein bisschen, aber wir haben es ja alles dokumentiert. Naja, also was haben wir denn bisher ausgegeben? Insgesamt haben wir seit Januar 2021 über 60.000 Euro an Honoraren gezahlt und fast 2.000 Euro im Namen von Gästen gespendet. Und damit ihr so ein Gefühl bekommt, dafür was wir pro Jahr spenden, weil das ist tatsächlich von Jahr zu Jahr gestiegen, eben weil wir unseren Output gesteigert haben, im letzten Jahr haben wir exakt 20.000 Euro an Gäste überwiesen netto. Umsatzsteuer habe ich logischerweise hier rausgenommen, weil die wird ja durchgereicht. Das heißt, ihr seht, es ist ein ordentlicher Batzen und das ist auch in der Gesamtsumme was, auf das wir sehr sehr stolz sind. Also das ist, ich habe jetzt gerade die Abrechnungen für April gemacht, die Honorar-Abrechnung und ich bin schon dreistellig. Wir sind jetzt schon bei einer Honorar-Abrechnung. Ich glaube, bei 103 werden wir sein, wenn ich damit fertig geworden bin. Das ist schon toll, 100 über 100 Abrechnungen, jetzt allein von 1. Januar bis jetzt. Ist einfach super, zeigt aber auch, dass jede Erhöhung ganz schön reinhauen würde, weil wir eben hier einen großen Hebel haben. Wir haben viele viele Leute, die einen Honorar bekommen oder viele einzelne Abrechnungen. Und wenn wir da jetzt zum Beispiel 10 Euro erhöhen würden, dann hört sich das nicht viel an, von 50 auf 60 Euro. Aber tatsächlich wird es uns wirtschaftlich killen. Dann werden wir quasi, wir wollen ja nicht wirtschaften wie Bundesligisten, sondern wir wollen es ja besser machen. Und aus den vorhin genannten Gründen und weil eben dieser Hebeleffekt zu groß ist, haben wir immer wieder dieses Thema verschoben und es ist uns auf den Zeige gegangen. Wir selbst sind uns auf den Zeige gegangen, dass wir das nicht hinbekommen haben. Gleichzeitig ist es, das ist natürlich jetzt auch so ein bisschen dann meine Sicht, als selbstständiger freier Journalist ja auch, ist es sowieso ein großer Makel an Honorarsetzen für freie AutorInnen. Dass da keinerlei Inflationsausgleich oder irgendwas mit dabei ist. Du kriegst, du vereinbarst irgendwann mal 2016 mit, keine Ahnung, t-online oder web.de oder Spox oder wem auch immer vereinbarst du einen Satz, sagen wir einfach mal 100 Euro pro Text. Das wäre schon gar nicht so schlecht bei dem meisten, muss man sagen. Und zehn Jahre später bekommst du immer noch diese 100 Euro abgerechnet. Aber natürlich hat sich alles drum herum verändert. Und aus diesen beiden Gründen, zum einen, weil wir es einfach nicht gebacken kriegen, diesen großen Schritt regelmäßig anzugehen, aus verschiedensten Gründen, und auch aus dem Grund, dass wir sagen, es ist grundsätzlich hier eigentlich ein Fehler eingebaut, dass eben diese Honorare sich nicht anpassen an die wirtschaftliche Situation, werden wir ab jetzt, ab Erscheinen dieser Sendung, einen Automatismus einführen. Und zwar werden wir jetzt jedes Jahr, in diesem Jahr eben ab Veröffentlichung dieser Sendung, das heißt irgendwann 1. Mai oder so, und ab kommendem und dann in Zukunft immer ab dem 1. Januar steigen unsere Gäste und Moderationshonorare immer um 3%. Wir werden das dann auch immer noch kommunizieren. Und das hört sich immer noch nicht viel an. Ist es de facto auch quasi für jeden einzelnen Gast noch nicht und wird zu sehr viel unrunden Beträgen führen. Ich freue mich schon sehr auf die Honorarberechnung. Jetzt kann ich nie mehr alles im Kopf machen. Frank, das ist echt ein Problem. Aber wir glauben, dass das jetzt der richtige Schritt ist, dass es auch das richtige Signal ist. Und wir werden beobachten, wie dann sich euer Überweisungsverhalten verändert. Vielleicht wollt ihr ja dann auch immer drei Prozent drauflegen pro Jahr, was dann ja auch nicht für jeden einzelnen viel ist. Und dann können wir gucken und es ist absolut nicht ausgeschlossen, dass wir da vielleicht auch noch mal ein paar Prozentpunkte höher gehen. Es ist jetzt das konservativ gerechnete Szenario, auch mit der Unsicherheit, wie viele Überweisungen wir jetzt verlieren mit dem Kontowechsel, dass wir sagen, da kommen wir auf jeden Fall wirtschaftlich mit hin und das ist immerhin, ja wir sind es dann immerhin angegangen und dann aber ist es auch fix, dass es sich jetzt immer erhöht und dann müssen wir da auch nicht immer drüber rechnen und diskutieren. Das ist, glaube ich, ganz gut.
Ich glaube ein ganz wichtiger Punkt darin ist auch natürlich zu erkennen quasi diesen Zinseszenseffekt. Also eine 3% Erhöhung ist ja, was ja der Punkt an der ganzen Sache ist, das ist jetzt unsere Zusage, dass wir das über Jahre hinweg machen. Das heißt, diese 3% wachsen natürlich als absoluter Betrag in jedem Jahr, weil ja die nächsten 3% wieder dann auf den erhöhten Betrag kommen und so weiter. Anhand dessen haben wir sonst mal durchgerechnet, was diese prozentualen Erhöhungen so machen würden. Was ist bei 5%, was ist bei 7%, was ist bei 2%? Und am Ende sind wir deshalb bei 3% gelandet, weil Max hat ja eben gesagt, weil wir einen gewissen Konservativismus walten lassen wollen hier, weil wir eben nicht nach zwei Jahren wieder zurückkurbeln wollen und sagen, okay, wir müssen das jetzt ändern. Das funktioniert nicht, weil unser höherer Wachstum, unser supporter Wachstum da nicht mithält. Die 3% sind etwas, die uns den Raum lassen, dass selbst wenn mal in einem Jahr aus irgendwelchen Gründen das Apport schwächer ist, wir immer noch damit klarkommen. Und das ist für uns ganz wichtig, weil wir da halt eine gewisse Stabilität einfach wollen.
Und das ist eine Verlässlichkeit für die Gäste und beantwortet vielleicht auch die Frage, die hin und wieder mal im Forum kam nach diesen Sendungen, die wir hier aufnehmen. Warum wollt ihr eigentlich immer weiter wachsen? Das ist ehrlicherweise schon auch ein kleines Argument. Also wir bewegen uns halt in einer Welt, in der um uns herum sich alles verändert und in der Regel teurer wird mit der Inflation. Und dann braucht es auch ein gewisses Wachstum, neben natürlich auch noch anderen Gründen. Also das ist jetzt nicht der einzige Grund. Wir wollen natürlich auch die Welt herrschaft. Das ist ja völlig klar. Wär ja Quatsch, wenn nicht. Wir sind ja im Fußball unterwegs. Nichts anderes als das Streben nach der Spitze ist der Kern des Fußballkapitalismus. Aber ja, wir glauben, dass das eben jetzt eine gute Lösung ist. Wir hoffen, dass unsere Gäste das auch als eine Wertschätzung empfinden, die natürlich eigentlich noch viel, viel höher ausfallen müsste. Aber es ist ein erster Schritt und das summiert sich ganz schön auf. Also als wir so durchgerechnet haben mit Zinseszinseffekt und wir haben das alles auf zehn Jahre dann immer hochgerechnet, weil wir sind jetzt zehn Jahre alt geworden. Wir wollen um mindestens 20 werden. Da hast du dann schon gesehen, ja gut, also die zehn Prozent, die ich ursprünglich mal so im Kopf hatte, einfach weil es so eine schöne Summe war. Nee, nie im Leben. Da müssten wir hier Venture Capital reinholen bei zweistelligen Renditen. Naja, also das ist das Thema Gästehonorare. Liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, gebt uns gerne Feedback. Ich bin gespannt, was ihr dazu sagt. Und dann, ja, schauen wir einfach mal, wie sich das jetzt alles entwickelt im Rasenfunk. Aber wir sind sehr froh, dass wir endlich eine Regelung gefunden haben, wo wir dann auch nicht jedes Jahr immer noch auf den buchhärterischen Abschluss und so weiter warten müssen, um sagen zu können, können wir uns jetzt xy leisten, sondern jetzt preisen wir es einfach ein und dann wird das schon werden.
Das ist tatsächlich nämlich ein Teil des Problems, dass die einerseits weiß man natürlich erst am Ende des Jahres, wie es das Jahr gelaufen, klar, weil...
Ja nicht mal am Ende des Jahres, oder? Eigentlich immer erst so im Mai, Juni des nächsten Jahres.
Zumindest was die Rohnen, die Zahlungseingänge angeht. Dann kommt im Mai, Juni irgendwann, je nachdem, wie schnell das Steuerbüro das schafft, das Abschlussthema dazu. Und dann kommt natürlich auch unsere Planung. Ich meine, wir haben jedes Jahr Änderungen, Anpassungen. Max und ich sitzen jetzt in fünf Wochen oder so wieder zusammen zu einer Klausurtagung für den Rasenfunk und haben schon einige größere Dinge da auf dem Zettel zu besprechen. Und das beeinflusst natürlich alles. Solche Dinge wie auch die Honorare, weil es ist natürlich auch immer wieder ein Thema, wie viele Sendungen werden von anderen moderiert, wie viele Gäste haben wir, haben wir ein neues Format, haben wir Formatänderungen, ändert sich die Anzahl der Gäste. Und dadurch ändern sich natürlich dann unterm Strich die Gesamthonorare. Und ja, insofern so interessant und lockerer Rasenfunk oft ist, aber so sehr ist es halt doch ein Business und gebunden an die ganzen auch bürokratischen Elemente. Wie die Honorar-Abrechnung und mitwirkenden Verträge und sowas.
Ja, und wir versuchen halt keine Influencer zu sein. Also wir wollen halt nicht der Influencer sein, der die Kohle ausgibt, die er verdient und dann zwei Jahre später insolvent geht oder irgendwie in seinem Twitch-Stream dann die Leute dazu auffordert, ihm Geld zu überweisen, weil das Finanzamt jetzt im Nachhinein noch Geld von ihm haben wollte, was er nicht hätte ausgeben sollen. So wollen wir halt nicht sein und deswegen sind wir da zurückhaltender.
Vielleicht bin ich ganz froh, manche Dinge nicht zu kennen.
Ja, ich habe auch schon gemerkt, du hast die... Ich glaube, dass manche, die hier zuhören, die werden gerade erkannt haben, auf wen ich da gerade...
Ich meine, dass mir die letzten Tage irgendwas in die Quere gekommen ist, aber ich habe nichts näher damit zu tun und ich glaube, ich will es gar nicht wissen.
Also auch ein Problem, wenn man fünf Bitcoins hat, aber sie jetzt nicht verkaufen kann, weil einfach der Kurs so schlecht ist, Frank. Dann müssen halt die Leute bitte Merch kaufen. Anderes Thema, ganz ganz anderes Thema. Und das ist nämlich auch sehr sehr wichtig. Mit Blick auf unsere Klausurtagung, was wirklich ein sehr antikes Wort ist. Fast jetzt würden wir in ein Konklave gehen, um über den Rasenfunk zu entscheiden. Wir wollen mal wieder eine Hörerinnenbefragung durchführen, denn wir haben Fragen und nur ihr habt die Antworten, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Ihr werdet die in den Show Notes finden und ich werde euch jetzt quasi so, wie ich euch mit der Kontoumstellung genervt habe, in den vergangenen Wochen in den Sendungen, werde ich euch jetzt mit der Hörerinnenbefragung nerven. Warum wollen wir das machen? Weil wir auch durch die Umstellung auf die Mehrfeeds, durch die Aufteilung auf Schwerpunkt- und Spieltags-Sendungen und auch durch Gastmoderation, die wir jetzt viel häufiger mit dabei haben, das Gefühl haben, weniger denn je zu wissen, wie das eigentlich bei euch ankommt. Denn wir haben einen ganz treuen Kern im Discord und im Forum, der uns Feedback gibt. Wir haben auch so Vorbeigucker, nenne ich sie mal, die auf YouTube dann ihr Feedback geben. Aber wir wissen ja, dass das nur die Spitze des Eisbergs ist. Und wie es dahinter, darunter aussieht, unter der Wasseroberfläche, das wäre für uns sehr wichtig zu wissen. Auch bei manchen. Wir werden sehr wahrscheinlich auch harte Entscheidungen treffen müssen in den nächsten Monaten, weil gewisse Dinge auch an ihre Grenzen gestoßen sind. Ich denke, dass wir da später vielleicht auch nochmal kurz zwei, drei Takte zu sagen. Und das wollen wir eben nicht nach einem Gefühl heraus machen, nicht nach unserer Präferenz machen, sondern wir wollen es eigentlich so machen, wie ihr das in der Summe gerne hättet. Vielleicht nicht jeder und jede einzelne, aber eben dann in der Summe. Und dafür brauchen wir Rückmeldung. Deswegen, bitte füllt diese Hörerinnenbefragung aus. Wir haben uns an einem Design von Stay Forever orientiert. Ganz herzlichen Dank dafür. Und es geht eben zu den Fragen, welche Sendungen hörst du eigentlich? Wie empfindest du die einzelnen Sendungen? Wenn ihr da ein Format nicht hört, dann überskippt ihr das einfach. Aber auch die Frage zum Beispiel, auf welche Sendungen könntet ihr verzichten? Ob ihr uns unterstützt? Und wenn ja, warum? Wie ihr uns gefunden habt? Und auch die Fragen, was ihr eigentlich sonst so konsumiert im Fußballbereich, weil sich auch gerade da so viel getan hat in den letzten zwei Jahren. Wie ihr das auch spüren? Da komme ich dann im Download-Teil nochmal mit dazu. Also bitte macht bei dieser Hörerinnenbefragung mit. Ich glaube, wenn man fix ist, dann ist man da also ganz fix. Das sind glaube ich in zehn Minuten durch. Wenn man noch darüber nachdenken muss, eine Viertelstunde. Aber arg viel länger dauert es eigentlich nicht, diese Fragen zu beantworten.
Ja, ich wollte das gerade nochmal unterstreichen. Das ist halt für uns ein Weg, eine Sicht auf einen Durchschnitt eurer Wünsche und eurer Wahrnehmung unserer Sendung zu bekommen, die wir ansonsten nie bekommen. Weil natürlich ist jeder, jeder Feedback-Post im Forum super wertvoll. Und übrigens am besten im Forum per E-Mail ist es oft das Problem, dass es viel anstrengender ist, das alles zu konsumieren. Fürs Forum nimmt man sich immer ein bisschen Zeit und schaut sich alles an. Das ist wesentlich leichter. Und so habt ihr auch gleich ein bisschen Feedback von den anderen Hörern. Aber dort ist es halt immer ein Eindruck weniger Nachrichten. Das heißt, selbst wenn fünf Leute was zu einer Sendung schreiben, dann kann man zwar vielleicht eine Tendenz erahnen. Man weiß aber nicht, was denken eigentlich die 20.000 im Durchschnitt, die die Sendung gehört haben, sondern es sind halt immer Evidenzen im Grunde. Und da sollte uns diese Umfrage deutlich helfen, einen besseren Blick zu bekommen und vielleicht uns für die Zukunft ein bisschen anleiten und uns zu zeigen, wo geht die Reise hin? Was ist euch wichtig? Was ist euch weniger wichtig? Ja, bitte macht die Umfrage.
Denn der Rasenfunk ist ja euer Ding. Das ist nicht nur unser Ding, sondern das ist unser gemeinsames Ding. Jetzt habe ich quasi alle drei. Also gehört euch, uns, aber uns auch gemeinsam. Aber ihr wisst ja, wie ich es meine, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer.
Wir machen es ja für euch.
Ja, eben. Und das war immer schon der Kern des Rasenfunks, dass wir quasi auf euer Feedback hin das ganze Produkt angepasst haben. Es war ja nicht so, dass wir über alle Spiele gesprochen haben von Anfang an. Und es war nicht so, dass wir Vereinsschwerpunkte hatten. Und es war nicht so, dass wir vom Beginn an den Plan hatten, ein kurzes Format einzuführen, ein langes Format. Das wollten wir immer einführen. Das kurze Format war erst mal nicht geplant. Und all die Dinge, die wir so gemacht haben, die sind immer entstanden, weil wir das Gefühl hatten, nicht für uns ist es jetzt so viel geiler, sondern es ist für euch besser. Also warum teilen wir auf einmal in fünf Feats auf und machen damit ein Riesenthema auf für Homepage und so weiter und so fort? Weil wir das Gefühl haben, ihr findet euch nicht mehr zurecht oder ihr findet manche Sendungen nicht mehr. Und dann denken wir darüber nach, okay, wie machen wir das? Und natürlich haben wir da einen Eigennutz. Aber ich denke, der Punkt ist klar geworden. Deswegen macht da bitte mit, auch wenn ihr vielleicht sonst euch noch gar nicht gerührt habt bei uns. Das ist gar kein Problem. Das ist, glaube ich, eine schnelle Möglichkeit. Link gibt es in den Show Notes, sowohl beim Video, bei YouTube, als auch jetzt hier in eurer Podcast App. Werdet ihr finden und ich werde es auch die nächsten Wochen immer mal wieder noch sagen.
Sehr gut.
So halb sind wir schon ins nächste Thema reingerutscht, Frank. Meinst du nicht?
Genau, so halb sind wir drin. Ich bin, glaube ich, an der Reihe, uns ein kleines Technikupdate zu geben. So sehr viel Konkretes gibt es da gar nicht. Viele Dinge, die im Moment passieren, laufen schon recht lange, teilweise viel zu lange leider. Das liegt zu großen Teilen an mir, aber auch an ein paar technischen Schwierigkeiten. Wir sind seit längerem dabei und ich bin jetzt nicht mehr ganz sicher, welche Sachen wir in vergangenen Sendungen schon gesagt haben, aber wir sind im Grunde schon eine ganze Weile dabei. Die Website, die wir, ich muss gleich überlegen, wann. Wir haben die neuen Feeds mit ein paar neuen, mit so einem kleinen Farbupdate, glaube ich, vor zwei Jahren gemacht. Und die Website eigentlich, so wie wir sie jetzt haben, vor drei oder vier Jahren.
Ja, irgendwas so dazwischen, glaube ich.
Auf jeden Fall sind wir gerade dabei, das alles wieder ein bisschen auf Vordermann zu bringen. Sprich in erster Linie zu Grunde legend das Backend, also quasi Datenbank und alles, was im Hintergrund passiert. Haben wir schon gemacht, haben wir auf eine neue Version gestellt und ein bisschen optimiert. Und am Frontend, also an der sichtbaren Website selber, sind wir nun schon eine ganze Weile dran. Da haben wir so ein paar Probleme, die wir schon länger lösen wollen. Zum Beispiel, dass es relativ lang dauert, wenn man die Startseite aufruft, bis die Sendungen erscheinen und so. Das sind Software bedingte Schwierigkeiten, die wir mit der alten Version so nicht mehr lösen konnten. Und die neue Version hat uns vor einige Probleme gestellt beim Updaten. Und so zieht sich das leider ein bisschen. Aber da sind wir immer noch mit befasst. In der Zwischenzeit hat dann die Newsletter Software, glaube ich, dreimal tatsächlich sich komplett verändert im Hintergrund. Ja, alles ein bisschen, was ich vorhin schon angesprochen habe, ein bisschen auch unsere eigene Schuld, dass wir halt quasi ein relativ komplexes System da haben, was uns jetzt auch jedes Update ein bisschen erschwert. Aber das sind die Geister, die wir riefen, würde ich sagen. Also da will ich auch gar nicht klagen. Das ist halt leider so.
Wir sind halt auch ein komplexer Podcast. Also das meine ich jetzt nicht schulterklopfend, sondern halt die vielen verschiedenen Formate, die Finanzierungsform, der Erklärungsbedarf der Finanzierungsform, die Art, wie wir Feedback unbedingt haben wollen und deswegen eben nicht drauf verzichten können, dass irgendwo eine Kommentarspalte unmoderiert einfach rumliegt und wir sie nicht sehen. Das hat halt alles zu so einem Konglomerat geführt, dass wir diese Homepage als Basis brauchen. Plus wir sind uns halt sehr bewusst, dass wir uns nicht zu sehr in die Abhängigkeit von irgendwelchen Drittanbietern geben wollen. Also wenn uns eben Twitter als riesiger Kanal wegbricht, weil da einfach ein faschistisches Arschloch das Ding übernimmt, dann tut uns das weh, aber wir müssen uns so aufstellen, dass es uns möglichst wenig auf weh tut. Und genauso ist es übrigens auch mit YouTube. Wir freuen uns darüber, dass wir bei YouTube gerade wachsen. Wir sind uns aber sehr bewusst, wenn wir es nicht schaffen, den ein oder anderen und die ein oder andere von YouTube zum Supporter und zur Registrierung zu bewegen oder ins Forum zu bewegen oder in den Discord zu bewegen, dann kann es sein, dass wenn YouTube mal wieder am Algorithmus dreht und wir noch schlechter dastehen als aktuell schon unmodetarisiert mit unseren langen Videos, dass wir dann einfach gar keine Möglichkeit haben, diese Menschen zu kontaktieren. Und auch deshalb war die Webseite für uns eben immer so im Zentrum von dem, was wir technisch gesehen gemacht haben.
Und ihr macht euch übrigens gar keine Vorstellung, wie schwierig es ist, diesen Medienbruch zu schaffen, also diesen Übergang von einem Podcast zu einer Webseite, also aus einem Podcast heraus jemanden dazu zu bewegen, sich bei einem Newsletter anzumelden, ist einfach ein Riesenproblem. Wenn ich irgendwo einen Blog habe und jemand liest meinen Blogbeitrag, dann kann ich da so ein Newsletter-Anmeldeformular dazwischen quetschen und kann ihm sagen, hey, wenn du dich hier anmeldest, dann schicken wir dir in Zukunft, wenn es neue Blogbeiträge gibt, zum Beispiel, ganz einfach, ganz nicht werblich, nicht spam, gar nichts. Aber diesen Übergang zu finden und zu sagen, du YouTube-Zuschauer, fühl dich ruhig angesprochen da draußen übrigens, abonniere vielleicht unseren Kanal, ja, aber schau auch mal auf der Website vorbei und guck mal, wie du uns unterstützen kannst. Dieser Bruch ist einfach sehr groß und sehr schwer zu überwinden.
Und gleichzeitig haben wir festgestellt, wenn ich das noch kurz sagen darf, dass aber, so wie für uns, die Homepage sehr, sehr zentral ist und wichtig ist und wir deswegen unheimlich viel Zeit und Geld da reingesteckt haben, um die möglichst schön und funktional zu machen, drückt sich das in den Klickzahlen überhaupt nicht aus. Also sie wird verwendet und sie ist wichtig und sie wird für immer der Anker bleiben, denn nur da versteht man überhaupt, was der Rasenfunk ist, wenn einem der Rasenfunk irgendwie begegnet. Aber Features, die wir uns überlegt haben, die vielleicht, also die ganz sicher eigentlich sehr toll wären auf der Homepage, aber die werden wir jetzt sehr wahrscheinlich nicht angehen, weil wir sehen, das lohnt sich dann leider doch nicht, weil wir geben dafür ja dann auch viel Geld aus. Euer Geld geben wir dafür aus und wir sehen, dafür gehen dann doch zu wenige in jedem Monat auf diese Webseite. Ich glaube, das Forum hat immer noch mehr Zugriffe als die Webseite jeden Monat, wenn ich es gerade nicht komplett falsch im Kopf habe. Das kommt auch noch mit dazu, also dass wir das auch feststellen mussten. Und das hat auch die Art und Weise geändert, wie wir mit der Webseite umgegangen sind. Und ich meine, du kannst ja auch gerne nochmal die technische Basis davon nennen für die drei, vier Nerds, die dann auch alle Begriffe kennen. Ich weiß es selber nicht, obwohl ich ständig mit diesem Backend arbeite. Ich müsste mich jetzt selber einloggen und in der Fußzeile gucken. Aber du kannst ja auch gerne nochmal kurz abnerden, wie eigentlich die Webseite funktioniert.
Bevor ich das mache, wollte ich noch eine andere Sache loswerden, weil auf den Punkt eingehen, den du gerade genannt hast, mit deinem Twitter-Beispiel. Wir haben das auch schon das ein oder andere Mal gesagt. Und weil es gerade ein aktuelles Thema ist, Discord ist auch so ein Punkt. Es gibt ja diesen Rasenfunk Discord-Server inoffiziell. Vielen Dank an alle, die dort involviert sind. Und das managen. Aber Discord ist einfach auch eine abgeschlossene Plattform. Hier gehören die Inhalte nicht. Es hat einige funktionelle Nachteile, die nicht schön sind und an denen sich wahrscheinlich nichts ändern wird, solange Discord nicht ein wirtschaftliches Interesse hat, diese Funktionalität zu ändern. Jetzt steht bei Discord, das übrigens zu ungefähr 40 Prozent Tencent gehört, also dem chinesischen Staatskonzern, steht ein Börsengang vor der Tür, so wie es aussieht. Der CEO wurde ausgetauscht gegen eine sehr umstrittene Figur aus der Gaming-Szene. Ich gehöre jetzt nicht zu den Apokalyptikern. Ich denke nicht, dass sich Discord sehr verschlechtern wird. Aber es macht einfach nochmal klar, da gibt es keinen Einfluss. Es gibt die Daten nicht. Da kann man jetzt darüber diskutieren, ob das in dem Chat ohnehin so sonderlich wichtig ist, was vor zwei Wochen diskutiert wurde, weil es wird nie wieder jemand sehen. Aber genau das ist der Grund, warum wir das Forum so lieben, weil dort eben auch im nächsten Jahr noch die Diskussionen nicht nur sichtbar und über eine Suche zu erreichen sind, sondern immer noch gut nachvollziehbar und halbwegs strukturiert. So ein Chat ist natürlich, hat vielleicht auch einen anderen Anspruch, aber das ist der Grund, warum wir nie, um das nochmal an der Stelle zu unterstreichen, warum wir nie einen eigenen Discord-Server gemacht haben, obwohl es natürlich die Plattform der Zeit ist im Moment, wo nicht nur die Gaming-Szene stattfindet, sondern im Grunde alles. Ich glaube, ich bin in einem Espresso-, also Kaffee-Discord, also alles, was zum Thema KI passiert, passiert im Moment in Discord. Und so war es mit Krypto, zumindest vor ein paar Jahren noch. Ich bin da ziemlich komplett raus aus dem Thema, aber da war es das Gleiche. Es war alles Discord. Und im Moment kann man fast sagen, everything Discord, wenn sich irgendwo eine Community formt, dann auf Discord im Moment. Und es ist wirklich traurig.
Ja, es tut insofern weh aus zwei Gründen. Das eine ist, dass wir genau die Erfahrung schon mal gemacht haben, was passieren kann, wenn sich das Geschäftsmodell von quasi Discord ändert. Wir hatten das Rasenfunk, das Rasenfunktionsteam, das hatten wir auf Slack. Und wir haben auch unsere Kommunikation und unsere Organisation lief komplett über Slack. Und dann ändert Slack sein Geschäftsmodell, muss mehr Geld verdienen. Und du kommst eben dann bei, da war es so, dass man pro User hätte zahlen müssen, und das wäre irre viel Geld gewesen, das wäre es nicht wert gewesen.
Und sie haben die Kostenlosen massiv eingeschränkt. Sie haben, glaube ich, die History massiv verkürzt. Und wir hatten schlagartig keinen Zugriff mehr auf unsere Chat History, die bis dahin noch irgendwie ein Jahr zurückging oder so.
Genau. Und dann war einfach von einem Tag auf den anderen, war Slack für uns tot und auch fürs Rasenfunktionsteam tot. Und letztlich muss man sagen, das hat das Rasenfunktionsteam gekillt. Wir haben versucht, das dann mit einem internen Bereich im Forum abzubilden, hat nie funktioniert. Und die Zeiten sind dann auch vorbei. Hatte sicherlich auch noch andere Gründe. Aber das ist eben schon passiert. Und das kann auch sehr wahrscheinlich mit Discord passieren. Und das, was aber das Ganze so schmerzhaft für mich macht, ist, dass ich es liebe, zu sehen, wie in dem offiziellen Discord ein Safe Space entstanden ist. Auch durchaus ein bisschen unterschiedlich zum Forum, weil, glaube ich, noch mal eine andere Art von Mensch überhaupt sich bei Discord anmeldet. Da gibt es ja auch noch mal durchaus eine Hürde. Also ich denke, dass auch manche der Hörerinnen sich jetzt denken, Discord, was habe ich noch nie gehört? Warum soll das so wichtig sein? Ist nicht schlimm, bleibt da, wo ihr seid. Guckt euch an, wenn es euch interessiert. Aber es ist ein Safe Space und ich mache mir aber schon Sorgen darüber, was passiert, wenn dieser Safe Space, auf welchen Gründen auch immer, uns genommen wird oder den Hörerinnen genommen wird. Deswegen, es gibt auch manche Discord-ähnliche Funktionen in der Forum-Software, die wir verwenden. Vielleicht geht es irgendwann mal in diese Richtung. Vielleicht kann man auch geschlossene Bereiche im Forum dafür irgendwann mal aufmachen.
Es ist halt das übliche Plattformproblem, Max. Discord, fast jeder würde ich jetzt mal sagen. Also sehr viele Menschen haben eine Discord-Account und sehr viele Menschen haben bereits Themen, die über Discord abgedeckt werden. Und damit ist das alles in einer App. Also es ist ein klassisches Plattformproblem. Mein Account existiert eh schon. So ein Invite-Link für einen Rasenfunk-Server klicke ich an, bin dort registriert, bin sofort drin, muss nichts machen, hab nicht den Bruch. In einem Forum muss ich einen extra Tab im Browser aufmachen. Das ist für uns, sage ich jetzt mal so, die Generation, die seit 20 Jahren im Internet unterwegs ist, nichts Besonderes. Aber gerade Jüngere oder solche, die vielleicht noch nicht so lange so aktiv sind, tun sich halt einfach viel leichter. Und sind es gewohnt, einfach nur mal schnell eine App zu öffnen und hinzuklicken und fertig, ohne einlocken, ohne registrieren. Die machen schon viel richtig. Und Discord hat ja von Anfang an viel richtig gemacht durch die hohe Audioqualität. Das war mal der Ursprung. Für Voicechats hatten die einfach viel bessere Qualität als damals Teamspeak. Und Teamspeak hat lange gebraucht, um danach zu ziehen. Und haben dann die Gamingwelt erobert und mittlerweile eben viele andere Bereiche. Nur jetzt wird es losgehen. Man wird sehen, dass ohne diese Nitro-Abo, ohne dieses bezahlte Abo, der Werbedruck steigen wird. Spätestens wenn der Börsengang kommt, geht es darum, die Kuh zu melken. Das ist einfach blanke Realität und das wird auch Discord verändern.
Ja, sehr richtige, richtige Einwand. Aber jetzt, Frank, erzähl uns noch ganz kurz was zu Laravel Nova Version 4.3.5.6 Silver Surfer.
Laravel Nova ist tatsächlich, Nova ist quasi das Frontend zum Backend, also die sichtbare Seite des Backends. Laravel ist unser gewähltes PHP-Framework für das zugrunde liegende Backend, also die ganze Funktionalität, die ganze API basiert auf Laravel. Und wir nutzen Nuxt im Frontend, ein Vue.js basiertes Frontend Framework. Und jetzt hat Max eigentlich schon mit Beginn meines ersten Satzes abgeschalten. Und ihr hoffentlich auch, die meisten von euch. Denn für euch ist es eigentlich gar nicht relevant, für diejenigen, die es kennen. Die freuen sich jetzt vielleicht über ein bisschen Info, aber tatsächlich ist das auch gar nichts Spektakuläres. Also es ist tatsächlich alles relativ weit verbreitet und gängig jetzt nicht unbedingt im Podcast-Umfeld, weil eben wenige so verrückt sind, sich so was Individuelles zu stricken, weil auch die wenigsten Podcaster den technischen Hintergrund dafür haben und wahrscheinlich froh sind. Da sind wir wieder bei dem Plattformthema. Was ja auch ein Grund ist, warum viele einfach zu Spotify gehen, um ihren Podcast zu veröffentlichen und vielleicht überhaupt keine Website haben. Oder eben von Porigy zum Beispiel diese einfache Lösung in Anspruch nehmen mit einer ganz einfachen Seite, die im Grunde ein bisschen ein Feed anzeigt. Ja, das ist ja auch absolut valid, ne?
Wenn du reiner Sender bist, dann reicht dir ja die Plattform und dann reicht es eine Website. Aber wir wollen ja auch Empfänger sein. Und deswegen haben wir eben Naxt und Laravel. Und ich freue mich mal, wenn es ein neues Update gibt und dann Dinge schneller laufen. Und es ist sehr beeindruckend, was du da dann immer hin programmierst. Ich meine, die Rückmeldung, die wir gerade aus der Podcast-Tech-Community bekommen haben auf den Launch der Seite, die waren sehr eindeutig. Die waren nämlich quasi, kannst du das für uns auch machen? Du wusstest aber, der Aufwand, der dahintersteht, und hast gesagt, im Leben nicht, auf gar keinen Fall. Und dann gibt es ja noch ein Experimentierfeld von uns, bei dem wir gerade aktiv sind. Transkripte werden immer wichtiger bei Podcasts. Magst du dazu noch zwei, drei Sätze sagen?
Im Grunde kann ich dazu gar nicht viel sagen, außer dass wir damit eben experimentieren. Transkription wurde besser durch KI vor allem. Es gibt von OpMayEye das Whisper-Modell, das schon vor relativ langer Zeit frei veröffentlicht wurde. Und im Gegensatz zu einigen anderen KI-Modellen, zu denen gehört, die auch auf so einem halbwegs modernen Computer lokal anstandslos laufen. Aber es gibt ein großes Problem dabei und das ist der Fußball. So schön es ist, dass der Fußball sehr international ist, so schwierig wird es durch die ganzen Namen. Und jetzt könnt ihr euch vorstellen, wenn wir so eine Rasenfunk Bundesliga Sendung transkribieren wollen mit drei Stunden Laufzeit und in jedem zweiten Satz kommt ein Spielername vor und der ist in der Transkription falsch, weil ihn jeder anders ausspricht und so weiter. Ich will ja gar nicht so detailliert drauf eingehen, aber das ist eine echte Challenge und das ist halt nun mal zentral für den Rasenfunk. Das heißt, das Problem ist für uns ungleich größer als für den durchschnittlichen Tech-Podcast, weil selbst das hinterher bearbeiten mit KI, was wir probiert haben, die Sache erst mal noch nicht viel besser macht. Wir müssen da noch tiefer einsteigen. Es gibt schon Möglichkeiten, quasi mit eigenen Wörterbüchern zu arbeiten, also wirklich gezielt Wörter zu trainieren, aber das ist alles sehr aufwendig. Für uns wird es eben nur dann interessant, wenn wir da eine hohe Trefferquote haben oder die zumindest gut genug ist, dass in der Transkription ein Name so weit richtig ist, dass ein Hinterherverarbeiten mit einer KI dazu führen würde, dass ich ihn korrekt korrigieren kann. Wenn allerdings teilweise komplett andere Wörter erkannt werden und daraus dann, weil ja auch die Transkriptionsmaschine quasi schon eine KI ist, daraus dann wirklich einen anderen Satz macht am Ende, dann wird es wirklich schwierig. Und das ist noch eine große Challenge. Die Transkripte, die wir teilweise schon von unseren Tools bekommen, wie hier Sandcaster, mit dem wir gerade aufnehmen, die sind alle schon recht gut, aber dieses Recht gut reicht halt leider nicht für uns. Und das Ziel wäre tatsächlich, unser ganzes Archiv zu transkribieren irgendwann. Das lohnt sich aber erst, weil das natürlich sowohl ein finanzieller als auch ein zeitlicher Aufwand ist. Es lohnt sich erst, wenn wir sagen, das Ergebnis ist wirklich so gut, dass wir einen Nutzen haben. Und dann sind natürlich viele Dinge denkbar. Und bei der Geschwindigkeit, mit der sich das ganze KI-Thema im Moment entwickelt, kann man sich vieles vorstellen. Was natürlich wirklich toll wäre, wäre eine KI-basierte Suche durch unser Archiv, dass ich wirklich Fragen stellen kann, wie wann haben wir eigentlich über die Trainerentlassungen von Dieter Hecking gesprochen oder so? Da kämen dann ganz viel, aber es käme zumindest mit sinnvollem Bezug.
Das war ein völlig unerwarteter Diss gegenüber Dieter Hecking.
Es war tatsächlich das, was mir spontan eingefallen ist.
Oder wann haben wir das erstmal über Kevin Kurani gesprochen? Oder wie hat sich eigentlich das, was wir gesagt haben, über den FC Bayern in den letzten Jahren verändert? Solche Dinge wären damit möglich. Letztlich würden wir damit das Format Podcast aufbrechen. Also wenn ihr euch da draußen vielleicht fragt, warum ist das denn für die so wichtig? Wir wissen auch noch nicht, wie wichtig es für uns ist, aber potentiell könnte es eben sein, dass das, was ihr eben alle hörend konsumiert, andere Menschen, denen das vielleicht nicht so liegt, dann anders konsumieren könnten. Also beispielsweise wäre auch denkbar, wenn es eben entsprechend auch gut umgesetzt wäre, dass automatisiert nach jeder veröffentlichten Folge ein Newsletter rausgeht an alle, die es abonniert haben. Also du bist dann auf dem Newsletterverteiler VfB Stuttgart und da bekommst du dann einen Link zur aktuellen Folge. Und da steht aber drin, die Gäste waren die Folgenden und die haben das grob zum VfB gesagt. Das hier sind die wichtigsten Zitate. Hier könntest du es auch noch hören, aber du hättest es eben auch in schriftlicher Form bekommen, auch barrierefreier als manche andere Dinge, die wir anbieten, wo wir zwar versuchen, auf Barrierefreiheit zu achten, aber es ist eben nie so ganz möglich, das zu 100 Prozent herzustellen. Also solche Dinge wären dann möglich. Wir würden letztlich den Rasenfunk dann nicht mehr nur als Podcast denken. Und das kann dann auch sein, dass es euch gar nicht betrifft, weil ihr hört das gerade und seid total happy damit, wie es ist. Vielleicht würden wir aber andere Leute, denen das Format vielleicht auch schon ein Problem darstellt, die könnten wir damit erreichen. Und das wäre ja schön, weil wir wollen ja mit unseren Inhalten erst mal Leute erreichen, die dann daran Spaß haben. Deswegen ist es etwas, über das wir nachdenken.
Und was man vielleicht auch noch sehen muss, jede Zeitung hat ein Archiv. Ein Archiv, das im Zweifelsfall durchsucht wird. Keine Ahnung, eine süddeutsche Zeitung greift wahrscheinlich ständig auch bei der Recherche auf das eigene Archiv zu, um zu sehen, was haben wir über denjenigen eigentlich schon geschrieben und so. Das ist für uns aktuell relativ schwer. Wir können das nur auf Basis der Shownotes tun, wenn überhaupt mit ordentlichen Transkriptionen und einer KI-Verbindung. Damit könnten wir das plötzlich auf einem ganz anderen Level tun. Und damit bekämen die vergangenen Sendungen auch eine ganz andere Relevanz, die sie heute gar nicht haben. Heute haben sie die Relevanz, weil man sie jederzeit wieder hören kann. Aber sie wirklich inhaltlich ranzuziehen geht halt eben nur, wenn man sie noch mal hört und dann sich Notizen macht entsprechend. Und das würde jetzt mit einer Transkription natürlich auf einem ganz anderen Level funktionieren.
Und ehrlicherweise, ich hatte das schon häufiger, weil ich jetzt ja auch schon Fußball historisch gearbeitet habe, bei F-Leben, beim Buch, Aus Liebe zum Spiel, aber ja auch bei manchen Tribünengesprächen. Das ist schon ein irrer Fundus, dass wir jetzt zehn Jahre Erstliga-Männer-Spiele haben, wo in der Regel jedes Spiel besprochen wurde. Und zwar ausführlicher als in dem Kicker oder sonstigen Artikel, den ich zu dem Spiel finden kann. Vielleicht auch noch mal ein bisschen nerdiger, als ich das da finden kann. Das, ich habe schon hin und wieder in alte Sendungen reingehört, weil ich mir gedacht habe, oh, da bin ich gespannt, was wir da gesagt haben. Ich habe dann mit Grausen festgestellt, dass entgegen unserer sehr zeitaufwendigen Bemühungen bei manchen alten Folgen immer noch die Kapitelmarken fehlen. Ich kann nicht sagen, warum, ist einfach so. Es nervt brutal. Aber das jetzt zu ändern, wäre wieder eine 3-Tages-Aktion. Und die 3 Tage hat keiner von uns beiden aktuell. Aber das käme eben auch noch mit dazu. Also wenn ihr euch im Bereich KI auskennt, wenn ihr Lust habt, an sowas mitzuarbeiten, ich sage das jetzt einfach mal so, Frank.
Vor allem Transkription. KI generell ist gar nicht so interessant, aber Transkription ist eigentlich im Moment so ein bisschen unser Kryptonit. Wobei ich dazu sagen muss, wir investieren da jetzt noch nicht so wahnsinnig viel Zeit. Es ist mehr, wir sind mehr in dem Stadium, es zu beobachten und Veränderungen immer mal wieder auszuprobieren und zu sehen, hilft es für uns. Aber wenn ihr da Erfahrung habt, vor allem was das Thema Speaker Diorization, also die Unterscheidung von Sprechern angeht, das wäre interessant für bereits gerenderte Folgen quasi.
Genau.
Aber wir haben im Moment auch das ganze Archiv noch als Mehrspur-Dateien. Das heißt, wir könnten auch die Spuren getrennt analysieren. Das ist nicht das größte Problem, aber vor allem, wenn es darum geht, kompliziertes Vokabular zu erkennen und da eine hohe Treffsicherheit hinzubekommen, dann nehme ich gerne jeden Tipp und jede Hilfe an.
Genau, wir hatten das ja schon zwei, drei Mal in der 10-jährigen Geschichte des Rasenfunks, dass Menschen sich mit irgendeinem technischen Thema beschäftigt haben und dann auf uns zugekommen sind und gesagt haben, hier können wir euch eine App programmieren oder können wir XY machen. Ganz herzliche Grüße an die Angesprochenen, hier mit indirekt Angesprochenen. Vielleicht ist es ja diesmal auch der Fall, dass ihr sowieso in dem Bereich Transkription unterwegs seid und da vielleicht auch einen großen Korpus bräuchtet an gar nicht so einfach verarbeiteten Daten. Den haben wir. Also damit können wir bieten. Wir stellen uns auch als Forschungsobjekt zur Verfügung. Sehr gerne. Waren wir ja linguistisch auch schon durchaus manchmal. Ganz herzliche Grüße an Simon an dieser Stelle. War es das mit dem Technik-Update?
Ich glaube ja.
Genug der Einsen und Nullen. Kommen wir zu euren Hörerinnen-Fragen, also jetzt der zweite große Block dieser Sendung. Und diesmal haben wir es eben so gemacht, wie vorher schon angekündigt, dass ich mir auch eure Fragen vorher angeguckt habe. Wir machen das jetzt nicht so, dass wir so grob über jede Frage drüber gehen, sondern wir haben auch versucht, sie inhaltlich zu gruppieren. Das heißt, es kann jetzt auch sein, dass eure Frage im Wortlaut nicht vorkommt. Ich denke aber, dass wir bis auf die privaten und hinter die Kulissen Fragen hoffentlich alles abgedeckt haben werden mit dieser Sendung. Und die erste Frage, die immer kommt, geht rund um die Downloads, um die Reichweite des Rasenfunks. Da hat zum Beispiel Hakuna Matata gefragt, hängen die Hörerinnenzahlen davon ab, wann der Podcast veröffentlicht wird? Gibt es einen Unterschied zwischen einer Sonntag- und einer Montagaufnahme? Und soll ich dir was sagen, Frank, als ich die Frage zum ersten Mal gelesen habe, was da meine Reaktion war? Das war eigentlich eine interessante Frage. Habe ich schon ganz lange nicht mehr nachgeguckt, ob es da einen Unterschied gibt. Und deshalb bin ich für Hakuna Matata und für alle anderen, die sich für unsere Downloads interessieren, bin ich wieder bei Podergy tief reingestiegen und bei YouTube und habe mir die Downloads rausgelassen. Es folgen jetzt viele Zahlen. Wenn das zu viel ist, dann schreibt es im Forum, dann kann ich die da auch nochmal posten. Das ist gar kein Problem. Ihr wisst ja, wir machen da kein Geheimnis drum um unsere Zahlen. Warum auch? Deswegen gehen wir jetzt mal die Feeds durch. Und der reichweitenstärkste Feed ist der der Bundesliga-Männer-Feed. Da habe ich jetzt jeweils die Zahlen zusammengesucht seit dem 1. Juli. Das heißt, wir haben so grob ein halbes Jahr mit drin, vielleicht ein bisschen mehr. Das ergibt einfach insofern Sinn, im August geht die Sendung los, im Juni rödelt der Rasenfunk Royale noch vor sich hin. Das heißt, ein guter Cut ist da zu machen. Wir hatten 1,1 Millionen Downloads seit dem 1. Juli und 730.000 Views bei YouTube.
Ganz kurzer Einwand, Max. Seit dem 1. Juli ein halbes Jahr. Ich glaube, das muss man erklären. Bis wann gehen die Daten?
Ach so, bis zum 1. April müsste das sein. Oder Ende März, genau. Also es ist ein bisschen mehr sogar.
Aber das ist ein bisschen mehr als ein halbes Jahr, oder?
Ja, das stimmt. Ich denke immer in Saisons, ehrlich gesagt. Das ist für mich so eine Hinrunde.
Das wollte ich nur aufklären, weil das klang für mich gerade ein bisschen.
Ja, okay. Du hast gesagt.
Nach mehr als einem halben Jahr, also es ist wahrscheinlich die Dreiviertel-Saison, weil da fehlt ja nur noch April und Mai und im Mai hört ja die Saison schon auf.
Ja, aber Mai kommt auch der Royale im Juni. Das heißt quasi, der haut halt richtig rein.
Und der ist da im Endeffekt nicht drin, weil 1. Juli natürlich nach der Saison ist.
Genau, und der Hintergrund war, dass ich möglichst aktuelle Zahlen haben wollte, auch nach der Aufteilung, Trennung, Schwerpunkt und Spieltagssendung. Also eben, wir haben so rund 1,8 Millionen Views bzw. Downloads. Dazu muss man aber sagen, das heißt erst mal gar nichts, wie viele davon auch wirklich wie lange reingehört oder reingesehen haben. Ist ganz schwer zu sagen. Das heißt, lasst euch jetzt auch nicht von... Wir wollen auch jetzt hier mit keiner Zahl flexen, weil kann man gar nicht sagen, wie viel so eine Sendung hat. Aber interessant ist natürlich die Entwicklung. Wir haben rund um die erfolgreichsten Sendungen sind immer Vorschau- oder Rückblicksendungen. Also die Vorschau, die hatte wieder rund die 40.000 Insgesamtdownloads und Views waren sogar noch ein bisschen mehr. Die Spieltagssendungen, die haben immer um die 25.000 Downloads und die Fokus-Sendungen haben um die 18.000 Downloads. Und ja, ich greife die Frage auf natürlich, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, ja, es variiert sehr deutlich zwischen den einzelnen Vereinen. Und ja, es ist ungefähr so, wie ihr es euch vorstellt. Bei YouTube ist es sehr, sehr schwierig, irgendetwas Generalisierendes zu sagen. Also da kann man quasi diese Aufteilung zwischen Spieltag und Schwerpunkt nicht so gut machen.
Lass mich noch mal ganz kurz rein, wenn du sagst, es variiert sehr stark, kannst du grob so die die Ausschläge nennen? Also so ein Bayern-Fokus hat der dann 35.000 Downloads?
Ne, ne, ne. Also interessanterweise kommen wir mit den Fokus-Sendungen eigentlich nie über die Spieltagssendungen raus. Was überraschend ist, weil die Halbwertszeit einer Fokus-Sendung ja viel länger ist und ich bekomme auch die Rückmeldung, dass Menschen manchmal ein paar Wochen später noch mal Schwerpunkt XY hören. Auf der anderen Seite muss man allerdings da auch sagen, dass die Download-Zahlen für die Spieltagssendungen sehr wahrscheinlich auch insofern geschönt sind, weil da wissen wir, dass es auch Leute gibt, die nur einzelne Kapitel zu einzelnen Spielen hören. Also das sind da nicht 25.000 Menschen, die diese Sendung von A bis Z durchgehört haben. Bei den Fokussendungen wird aber wahrscheinlich der Prozentsatz derjenigen, die das komplett gehört haben, viel höher sein. Das heißt, wenn man danach geht, kann es sein, dass die vielleicht sogar auf Augenhöhe sind.
Wie du schon gesagt hast, ist es immer schwierig mit solchen Download- und View-Zahlen zu operieren, weil die gerade bei so längeren Sendungen wie beim Rasenfunk generell ganz schwer eine Aussagekraft geben. Wer schon mal YouTube-Videos veröffentlicht hat, der kennt diese Retention, diese Fewer-Retention-Kurven. Wie lange bleiben die Zuschauer dran? Und da sieht man eben innerhalb der Videos immer ganz schöne Kurven und Veränderungen. Das ist beim Podcast am Ende genauso. Und daher lässt sich schwer. Darum gucken wir auch und darum ist es ja. Habt ihr am Anfang schon gehört, Max musste auch erst mal reingucken und fand die Frage interessant, weil so richtig abhängig machen wollen wir uns von den Statistiken ja auch nicht.
Genau für uns zählt die eine Zahl. Das ist was im Monat reingekommen ist an Überweisungen und an Support-Beiträgen. Und danach müssen wir uns richten. Bei YouTube ist es komplett erratisch. Wir haben einige alte Videos, die über 50.000 Views haben. Es gibt einige Spieltags-Sendungen, die haben über 30.000 Views. Also sprich, der Theorie nach mehr als sie Downloads hätten als klassischer Audio-Podcast. Der Schnitt ist allerdings viel niedriger. Der ist um die 13.000 für die Spieltags-Sendungen und auch für die Schwerpunkte durchaus. Und wir hören jetzt, wenn wir beim Audio-Podcast bleiben, 30 Prozent so grob wie Apple, Podcasts und Spotify. Und der Rest verteilt sich auf andere Plattformen. Spotify ist hier zurückgegangen in den letzten Jahren. Und interessanterweise ist auf Platz zwei der Länder, in denen wir gehört werden, ist die USA. Liegen die USA noch vor Schweiz und Österreich? Keine Ahnung, was da mit unseren direkten Nachbarn los ist. Aber es ist so, zumindest laut Podgy. Und um auf die Frage zu antworten, der Tag spielt keinerlei Rolle. Interessanterweise ist es aber so, dass in unseren Top Ten in dieser Saison die Spieltage eins bis sechs sind. Das heißt, es scheint so zu sein, dass die Saison-Vorschau-Menschen die den Rasenfunk nicht kannten, die dann vielleicht hängenbleiben, aber offenbar auch wieder abspringen. Denn irgendwann kommen wir dann wieder auf dem Normal-Dimo raus. Die Schwerpunkte hinken deutlich hinter den Spieltags-Sendungen hinterher. Also der erfolgreichste ist Bayern auf Rang 11, unsere Top-Sendungen St. Pauli dann auf 16, Hoffenheim auf 23, VfB Stuttgart auf 28 und Borussia Dortmund auf 30. Also speaking of, es ist nicht vorhersehbar. Es ist auch im Podcastbereich nicht vorhersehbar. Was aber insgesamt zu sagen ist, zu dem Feed Bundesliga Männer. Der Podcast stagniert von den Download-Zahlen her. Wir haben im Grunde ungefähr das, was wir in den Vorjahren auch schon hatten. Das ist eine Entwicklung, die haben wir seit mindestens drei Jahren, dass sich da eigentlich nicht mehr so wirklich viel tut. YouTube wächst, aber total erratisch. Es ist nicht nachvollziehbar und wir wissen ja auch, wie wichtig beim YouTube Thumbnail und Titel sind. Da sind wir schon ein bisschen pointierter geworden. Vielleicht müssten wir manchmal sogar noch mal das Thumbnail wechseln. Aber da haben wir auch gar keine Lust drauf, weil wir wollen eigentlich gar nicht so die Leute einfischen. Wir wollen schon, dass wir gefunden werden auf YouTube. Aber wir wissen ja, dass jemand, der auf ein total reißerisches Thumbnail klickt, dass der, wenn der dann sieht, das dauert jetzt zweieinhalb Stunden die Sendung, dass der dann sowieso wieder weg ist. Und wir sind nicht monetarisiert auf YouTube, was uns im Algorithmus definitiv auch schadet.
Und bei YouTube könnt ihr übrigens selber reingucken. Ihr seht ja die Few-Zahlen, ihr seht zwar keine Entwicklung, aber ich gucke hier gerade nebenbei auch aus Interesse auf die Bundesliga-Männer-Playlist bei YouTube. Und da sieht man ganz gut die Schwankungen. Da ist eben die Analyse vom 12. Spieltag bei 20.000 und die vom 14. bei 9.000. Da muss natürlich klar sein, Max hat es ja eben schon erwähnt, YouTube ist halt eine Algorithmus-Plattform. Selbst wenn ihr uns dort abonniert habt, wissen wir nicht, wie gut ihr mitbekommt, wenn wir ein neues Video veröffentlichen. Das heißt, ihr müsstet da schon in eure Abo-Ansicht gucken und alles entsprechend einstellen, damit ihr zuverlässig jedes Abo, jedes Video zu Gesicht bekommt, das ein abonnierter Kanal veröffentlicht. Wohingegen das selbst bei mir zum Beispiel, mein YouTube-Verhalten ist fast komplett Startzeiten abhängig. Und meine Startzeite ändert sich relativ schnell, wenn sich meine aktuelle Tendenz zu irgendwelchen Themen ändert. Ist ja okay und aus YouTube-Sicht völlig verständlich, ist aber für uns als Publisher natürlich ein sehr wenig berechenbarer Faktor.
Total. Ihr hattet das ja bestimmt auch schon, wenn ihr YouTube öfter verwendet, dass euch irgendwann auch fällt, hey, wo sind eigentlich die Videos von Kanal XY? Hat der oder sie gar nichts veröffentlicht? Und dann schaut ihr auf den Kanal und sagt, nee, der hat ganz normal im Rhythmus weiter veröffentlicht. Ich habe es einfach nicht mehr gesehen, weil ich den Fehler gemacht habe, ein Video zu was ist die Konklave, wie funktioniert sie anzugucken und mir jetzt nur noch das vorgeschlagen wird. Ich hatte das auch noch mit anderen Themen im letzten Jahr. Also was aber damit zu sagen ist, es macht keinen Unterschied, wann wir veröffentlichen. Die Downloads sind gut, sind auch so, dass viele, also independent Podcasts würden sich sehr freuen über solche Zahlen und die Corporate-Podcasts, die lachen da drüber. Aber es wächst nur noch auf YouTube. Das war ja auch der Befund, den wir schon die letzten Jahre hatten. Und da ist es aber auch total schwer zu timen. Und wir machen ja auch ganz viele Dinge gar nicht richtig für YouTube. Also am Anfang habe ich manchmal noch Sendungen später auf YouTube veröffentlicht, weil es eben da, du musst quasi den Sendungen Luft zum Atmen geben, in Anführungszeichen, dass sie eben ihre Views einsammeln können. Denn wenn ich zwei Sendungen kurz nacheinander veröffentliche, dann zeigt YouTube logischerweise, wenn, dann überhaupt nur eine davon auf der Startseite an. Aber irgendwann fand ich das dann albern, dass es den Audio-Podcast schon gibt und ich ans Video noch denken muss. Und dass ich damit ja auch die YouTube-Fans, die wirklich alles gucken, die gibt es ja auch, dass ich die dann damit benachteile und deswegen wird jetzt einfach wild rausgehauen. Und also das ist jetzt auch nicht so, das ist jetzt keine YouTube-Strategie, die wir da haben. Kommen wir in Abgrenzung zum Bundesliga-Männer-Feed, zum Bundesliga-Frauen-Feed. Ich versuche jetzt ein bisschen schneller durchzugehen. Da haben wir, also ihr erinnert euch Bundesliga-Männer, 1,1 Millionen Downloads und 700.000 Views. Beim Bundesliga-Frauen haben wir 50.000 Downloads und 35.000 Views. Also ein deutlicher Abfall. Aber hier sehen wir, dass sich was tut. Der YouTube-Schnitt ist so bei anderthalbtausend ungefähr, der Podcast-Schnitt so bei zweieinhalbtausend, 2,2. Ist auch hier schwierig zu sagen. Wir sehen allerdings, dass die Folgen gehört werden. Wir haben logischerweise bei diesem Feed auch keine Altkartei-Leichen mit drin. Das darf man auch nicht komplett vergessen. Leute, die uns für Ewigkeiten abonniert haben im Männerfeed und das noch auf der Autodownload haben, aber schon ewig nicht mehr reingehört haben, das haben wir in diesem neuen Feed logischerweise nicht. Das heißt, ja, die Zahlen sind deutlich niedriger. Ich nehme aber wahr, auch an der kleinen Community, die sich quasi in diesem Feed so ein bisschen zu bilden scheint, dass es da eine Entwicklung gibt und dass man sich da jetzt auch nicht blenden sollte, nur von den geringeren Zahlen und wir machen es ja nicht für die Zahlen. Deswegen, also ich muss sagen, mit der Entwicklung von dem Feed bin ich persönlich zufriedener als mit dem von Männerfeed. Frank nickt für alle, die jetzt nur hören. Schauen wir auf die Ligatur, unser, tja, Sorgen- und Lieblingskind. Man kann es nicht anders sagen. Ligatur hatte 300.000 Podcast-Downloads und 100.000 bei YouTube. Die große Frage ist, wie unterscheiden sich die Zweitligasendungen von den Europasendungen? Bei YouTube haben wir bei der zweiten Liga ein paar Ausreißer nach oben. Also wir hatten mal 12.000 bei einem HSV und lauter ein Video und 9.000 bei Fortuna Düsseldorf und Nürnberg. Man glaubt da schon herauszulesen bei YouTube, dass die etwas bekannteren und reichweitenstärkeren Vereine auch eine höhere Reichweite bekommen. Wobei man zum HSV, wie du dazu sagen musst, wenn Niesbohmhof da ist, haben wir natürlich auch die entsprechende Crowd.
Kleiner Livefun-Fact, das weil ich es zufällig beim Durchklicken gerade gesehen habe, das HSV Kaiserslautern Video ist das beste Video der letzten 90 Tage insgesamt.
Ah ja, guck mal.
Mit 12.500 Views innerhalb dieser 90 Tage.
Danke Nies für deinen Besuch. Das hat sicherlich auch geholfen, wobei wir nie jemanden deswegen einladen, aber das wisst ihr, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Die Downloads sind allerdings weniger als die europäischen Ligaturen. Nur in den Top-Folgen ist das so. Der Schnitt ist viel, viel niedriger. Der liegt so bei 9.000 bis 10.000 Views. Ist so ein bisschen schwer zusammenzurechnen. Und der Schnitt für die europäischen Videos, der liegt bei 11.000 bzw. bei 3.500 für die Einzelvideos und die Downloads liegen bei 11.000. Entschuldigung, ich habe hier gerade die Zahlen miteinander verwechselt. Aber was jetzt quasi jenseits von den Einzelzahlen für euch wichtig ist zu wissen. Also zum einen ist es so, dass kein Format der Liga Tour auch nur annähernd an irgendwas rankommt, was wir zur ersten Liga machen, bei den Männern. Und vor allem das Zweite ist, obwohl wir da jetzt Geld und Zeit investieren und eine Regelmäßigkeit herstellen, tut sich da leider immer noch gar nichts. Also weder das europäische Format noch das Zweitliga-Format hat irgendeine Entwicklung nach oben zu zeigen. Und wer ich nehme eigentlich auch nicht, war, dass sich da jetzt irgendwie eine neue Community drum herum bildet. Ich weiß, dass die Lieblingsformate von vielen von euch sind. Gerade das europäische Liga Tour-Format ist es von uns auch, ehrlicherweise. Es macht einfach sehr viel Spaß, mit einer etwas festeren Runde zu sprechen, die sich auch gut kennt und die einfach sehr viel Spaß hat, auch abseits des Mikrofons. Aber ehrlicherweise zeigt sich das trotz aller Bemühungen nicht in den Downloads. Und das kann vielleicht irgendwann mal auch zu Konsequenzen führen. Müssen wir mal gucken. Kann man jetzt so nicht sagen. Aber auch dafür haben wir die Hörerinnenbefragung. Bin mal gespannt, wie da die Rückmeldungen drauf sind.
Absolut, ja.
Tribünengespräch, der Podcast 85.000 Downloads, YouTube 22.000. Wir haben während der EM allein 23.000 Downloads gesammelt über die Nationalismus-Folge und die Polizeikosten-Folge. Bei YouTube haben wir immer so einen Schnitt von etwa 4.000 Views. So grob für ein Tribünengespräch. Ist ein bisschen schade, weil die Tribünengespräche ja eigentlich zeitlos sind und auch bei YouTube über die Suchfunktion häufiger gefunden werden könnten. Aber dann ist das Format wahrscheinlich doch zu sperrig. Insgesamt muss man sagen, dass es etwas enttäuschend ist, dass ausgerechnet dieses eigentlich mal so als Premium-Format gedachte Sendungstypus, jetzt wollte ich nicht nochmal Format sagen, dass das mit 16.000 Downloads dann doch gar nicht so viele Leute da draußen hören. Und ich habe den Eindruck, das ist aber auch ein bisschen ein selbstgemachtes Problem, weil es auch daran liegt, dass oft zu lange nichts passiert im Feed des Tribünengesprächs. Das wissen wir, es wäre natürlich einfacher, wenn ihr wisst, jeden Monat kommt ein Tribünengespräch, dann hört man da jeden Tag.
Eigentlich ein dauerhafter Painpoint bei uns.
Ja, Wahnsinn.
Wir sprechen da, glaube ich, auch schon zum fünften Mal in irgendwelchen Q&A-Folgen drüber. Eigentlich hätten wir uns für das Tribünengespräch immer viel mehr vorgenommen, als dann am Ende machbar ist. Und aus vielen anderen Gründen, weil halt natürlich die aktuellen Sendungen sich selber auf die Agenda setzen. Die Spieltage und EMs und WM dieser Welt und die Tribünengespräche sind da geduldig. Und zu diesem Thema, das Max vorhin schon angekündigt hat, werden wir ja vielleicht noch ein paar Takte sagen. Das macht es alles gar nicht einfacher im Moment. Deine Fußballtaktik bei fast 1000 Notiz musst du mir noch erklären, Max.
Ach so, ja, das ist, also ich habe quasi gerade gesagt, 16.000 haben die EM-Tribünengespräche geholt und das Polizeikosten. Und im selben Zeitraum hat das Fußballtaktik-Gespräch 1000 Downloads geholt. Weil das ist so ein Ever-Creep.
Immer noch.
Der wird immer noch gehört. Und ich liebe es. Ich hasse es natürlich, weil ich damals so noch viel schlechterer Moderator war und Audioqualität war noch nicht so gut. Und ich glaube, weiß gerade gar nicht, ob wir da überhaupt damals schon eine Intro-Musik hatten. Müsste ich noch mal reinhören. Und hoffentlich sind hier nicht die Kapitelmarken geschrottet. Fällt mir gerade siehend heiß ein, sollte man mal nachgucken. Aber ja, es ist schön zu sehen, diese Sendung geht hier ja um Downloads.
Gibt gar kein Video von dieser Sendung.
Es gibt kein Video von dieser Sendung.
Stell dir mal vor, es würde ein Video geben zu dieser Sendung.
Ja, vor allem mit Tobi Escher, der den ganzen Bonus-Liga-Feh mit reinholt.
Und Taktik-Tafel als dritte Kamera quasi.
Ja, wobei, das ist, haben wir ja auch schon oft darüber diskutiert, wie viel einfacher auch die Spieltagsbesprechung werden würde, wenn man mal was einblenden würde oder was zeigen würde. Aber die Gefahr wäre riesengroß, dass du es als Audio dann nicht mehr checkst. Deswegen würde ich Tobi Escher die Taktik-Tafel verbieten oder verboten haben. Kommen wir zum letzten Feed, die Nationalteams. 250.000 Podcast-Downloads, 90.000 bei YouTube. Wir haben EM-Folgen zum Teil da noch mit drin, weil da ja das Finale dann erst im Juli stattfand. Die EM-Folgen hatten immer so 16.000 bis 20.000 Downloads. Also wirklich sehr erfolgreich, kann man sagen. Auch im Vergleich mit den anderen Formaten. Und grundsätzlich ist es so, dass die Länderspiele der Männer so um die 13.000 Downloads als Podcast haben. Bei YouTube immer so zwischen 6.000 und 7.000 stehen. Und die der Frauen sind bei 7.000 Downloads und bei 2.000 bis 3.000 Views bei YouTube. Man muss dazu sagen, auch hier wissen wir natürlich auch nicht, ob Download jetzt bedeutet, man hat reingehört. Also vice versa. Sowohl jemand, der vielleicht wegen der Frauenspiele abonniert, der hört sich vielleicht die Männersendung nicht an und umgedreht, gibt es bitte auch, gibt es gewiss auch den Fall. Denn zwei, drei Leute, denen war es auch wichtig, uns das mitzuteilen, dass sie diese Sendung jetzt aber nicht hören. Danke, wir haben es gehört. Wir werden trotzdem über die Länderspiele der Frauen berichten, weil es ehrlich gesagt auch gerade ein bisschen spannender ist als bei den Männern. Und weil man hier eben auch sieht, gerade bei YouTube kann man das dann doch immer ganz gut ablesen. Da scheint sich so eine kleine Community zu finden. Und ganz interessant, während die Nationalteams folgen bei den Männern, selbst Leuten, die eigentlich beruflich den Auftrag haben, so ein bisschen im Blick zu behalten, was über den DFB gesagt wird, nicht wirklich ankommen auf die Frauensendung, da gibt es aber aus allen möglichen Richtungen aus dem Fußball-Business-Rückmeldung. Das kann ich euch sagen. Also das ist sehr, sehr interessant und macht natürlich auch Spaß. Dafür machen wir die Sache nicht, aber es ist ein netter Nebeneffekt. Wir hatten auch Copa America-Sendungen. Danke nochmal an Johannes, der das damals gerockt hat. Die lagen immer so bei 9000 Downloads, also so rund die Hälfte der EM-Folgen. Wie viele dann reingehörten, wissen wir nicht, aber es war auf jeden Fall interessant zu sehen, wie das.
Und der entscheidende Punkt bei all diesen Zahlen ist ja immer schön auf die Zahlen zu gucken und dann sagen wir natürlich, wie zufrieden wir damit sind oder ob wir gerne Wachstum sehen würden und so, wie wir immer wieder sagen. Und auch an dieser Stelle sollte es nochmal betont werden, am Ende zählt für uns natürlich zum einen eure Zufriedenheit, das heißt ja, eine ansteigende Download-Zahlen sind natürlich für uns auch eine Form vom Feedback, also Wachstum heißt auch, es kommt gut an. Das ist das eine. Und am anderen Ende, wenn es um das Finanzielle geht und um die Finanzierbarkeit des Rasenfunks, zählt natürlich, wie viele Supporter können wir gewinnen. Und diesen Connect kann man so direkt natürlich nicht herstellen, weil nur eine Ligatur der zweiten Liga, die jetzt enorm viele Views bekommt, erhöht natürlich nicht die Supporter-Zahlen. Insofern ist das immer so ein bisschen als Gesamtschwamm zu sehen, würde ich sagen. Wenn sich die Downloads insgesamt positiv entwickeln, bedeutet das für uns unterm Strich auch, dass sich wahrscheinlich die Supporter positiv entwickeln. Aber es ist natürlich immer ein sehr starker Gummibandeffekt. Der zieht so hinterher und ganz langsam und ist natürlich auch an sich schon schwer, statistisch zu erfassen, weil wir da im Grunde auch nur die Jahressumme zusammennehmen können und auch schlecht reinblecken können, was passiert da wirklich. Aber das ist eigentlich der einzige Grund für uns, die Download-Zahlen zu beurteilen, weil alles andere, wie Max schon sagte, ist für uns eigentlich gar nicht so relevant.
Deshalb füllt die Hörerinnenbefragung aus. Die ist für uns wirklich ein wichtiges Tool. Wir kommen zu inhaltlichen Fragen. Ich versuche jetzt auch ein bisschen schneller drüber zu gehen, damit wir möglichst viele Themenbereiche noch schaffen. Hakuna Matata hat auch gefragt, hast du einen Unterschied festgestellt, seitdem der Rasenfunk auch als Video veröffentlicht wird? Ich schaue aus Prinzip keine Podcasts bei YouTube und habe das Gefühl, dass in den letzten Wochen die nonverbale Kommunikation mehr wurde. Ich kann da tatsächlich mal eine kurze Antwort geben. Ja, ich sehe einen Unterschied und es ist alles besser geworden, dadurch, dass die Gäste sich jetzt gegenseitig sehen. Und zwar auch das Audioprodukt ist besser geworden. Denn ihr müsst euch das so vorstellen, vorher hatten wir ein Tool, da hat man nur einen Balken gesehen, wenn jemand gesprochen hat. Und ansonsten hast du gar keine Rückmeldung bekommen. Und ich habe sehr früh, als wir das mit Video gemacht haben, gemerkt, wie sehr das die Gäste entspannt, wenn sie in ihrem Monolog, den sie ja naturgemäß immer wieder haben, sehen, die anderen nicken, sie grinsen vielleicht mal bei einem Spruch, vielleicht tun sie auch schon mal so Luft und man merkt, ok, da habe ich jetzt was gesagt, da möchte jemand gleich noch einhaken. Es macht alles besser, sowohl das Audioformat als auch das Videoformat ist auch natürlich logischerweise jetzt mit einer Videospur auch gut. Also das hat sich wirklich sehr bezahlt gemacht und es macht mehr Spaß, damit aufzunehmen. Weitere Frage nach den Formaten. Wie zufrieden seid ihr selbst aktuell mit dem Produkt Rasenfunk, gerade nachdem sich inzwischen Änderungen wie die Feeds, Position des Werbeblocks, Abgabe der zweiten Liga, YouTube, Unterteilung von Spieltag und Schwerpunkt und so weiter und so fort etabliert haben. Dazu fragt auch noch Nono, ob ich eigentlich alle Rasenfunkfolgen höre, die ich nicht selbst moderiere. Aber auf jeden Fall Nono, aber ganz, ganz sicher. Ich versuche auch möglichst oft Feedback dazu zu geben und den Gästen auch nochmal zu danken. Und gibt es Gedanken dazu, wie man in Zukunft den Rasenfunk noch erweitern kann. Vielleicht ein Champions League Format. Flona Deniu hat diesen Evergreen der Rasenfunk-Fragen gestellt. Ich versuche jetzt auch hier nicht so sehr herum zu mehr anderen, weil da könnten wir jetzt natürlich sehr, sehr viel zu sagen. Also grundsätzlich glauben wir oder glaube ich, ich möchte jetzt nicht für dich sprechen, Frank, das gerne gleich ergänzen. Ich glaube, dass der Rasenfunk inhaltlich besser dasteht denn je. Die Aufteilung in Spieltag und Vereinsschwerpunkt war lange überfällig. Sag ich gleich noch was mit dazu, was das aber auch bewirkt. Die Art und Weise, wie wir die Sendung beginnen, hat zwar mein Audiodesign von Intro und Outro aufgebrochen, weil das Radio wird angeschaltet und das Radio wird abgeschaltet, weil wir sind ja der Rasenfunk. Eigentlich darfst du da nicht einen Codeopener davor machen, bevor das Radio angeschaltet wird. Ich glaube aber, dass es hilft. Manchmal überrascht das wahrscheinlich, wenn man quasi einfach die Podcast-Que durchhört und dann eben ohne Intro losgeredet wird. Ich glaube aber, dass es auch einfacher wird, eine Orientierung zu finden. Und wir sind ein bisschen entspannter bei der Begrüßung damit geworden, weil dann könnte man rein theoretisch auch mal einfach ein bisschen labern, bevor die Sendung losgeht. Also ich glaube inhaltlich, wir decken auch viel mehr ab als in der Vergangenheit und stehen mit Ausnahme des Tribünengesprächs-Feets wirklich sehr, sehr gut inhaltlich da. Aber, und jetzt kommt das aber, der Output ist brutal. Also ihr merkt es als HörerInnen denke ich ja auch, dass wir in der Regel stehen wir gerade bei vier Sendungen pro Woche. Und was ich, also was wir eigentlich wussten und deswegen haben wir diese Aufteilung in Schwerpunkt versus Spieltagssendung so lange nicht gemacht. Das war nicht nur ein finanzielles Thema, weil mehr Gäste, sondern vor allem eben eine Sendung mehr pro Woche. Und man unterschätzt es immer wieder, auch ich unterschätze es immer wieder, wie KO man nach einer Sendung sein kann. Also das ist im Grunde ist das nur anderthalb Stunden Gespräch und dann irgendwie noch eine Stunde Nachbearbeitung. Dann schaust du noch, dass alles passt und dann du kannst da rein theoretisch mit vier bis fünf Stunden Aufwand rauskommen. Das ist ja gar nicht so viel, da hat man ja noch einen halben Arbeitstag. Aber de facto ist es nicht so. Und wir stoßen da trotz aller Bemühungen mit Gäste, ModeratorInnen und so weiter und so fort. Wir stoßen da an Grenzen und müssen da auch gucken, wie es weitergeht, weil das ist ein Pensum. Das ist wahrscheinlich leider zu viel.
Oder zumindest so nicht weitermachbar. Und wenn Max wir sagt, dann geht es in erster Linie natürlich um Max, der da viel mehr und viel praktischer involviert ist als jeder andere. Aber auch das ist wieder ein Punkt, wo diese Umfrage ganz, ganz arg wichtig für uns ist, weil wir dafür ein bisschen mehr sehen müssen, wie schaut ihr auf die einzelnen Sendungen? Wie hört ihr sie? Wie wichtig sind sie euch? Wie beurteilt ihr sie? Das wird ein Punkt sein, an den wir irgendwie ran müssen. Das wird Teil unserer Besprechung in sechs Wochen sein. Aber das wird vor allem Gegenstand der nächsten Monate wahrscheinlich sein, um herauszufinden, wie organisieren wir gewisse Dinge? Wollen wir die eine oder andere Sendung anders strukturieren? Weil was natürlich jetzt nicht so deutlich rauskam, bei dem was Max eben gesagt hat, aber was ihr eigentlich, vor allem ihr als Hörer dieses Q&A, die ja wahrscheinlich regelmäßige Rasenfunk-Hörer seid, was ihr wisst, der wahre Aufwand steckt in der Vorbereitung. Der meisten Sendungen. Sprich allein zweieinhalb Tage wahrscheinlich gehen drauf, um die ganzen Sendungen, die ganzen Spiele des Spieltags zu sehen. Und was eben notwendig ist für eine tiefe Analyse, wie ihr es vom Rasenfunk gewohnt seid. Also die Frage wird für uns sein, an welcher Stelle können wir das managen mit zusätzlichen Menschen oder mit Veränderung der Formate oder vielleicht auch mit der Streichung des ein oder anderen Formats, keine Ahnung. Würde zwar davon jetzt nicht ausgehen, aber am Ende müssen wir halt gucken, dass vor allem die wichtigen Produkte nicht leiden, dadurch dass das Pensum insgesamt zu hoch ist. Ich glaube, das ist schon ein ganz wichtiger Punkt. Und da werden wir in den nächsten Wochen und Monaten irgendwie damit umgehen. Dass man meistens den Mut fassen muss, was größer zu ändern. Und wir haben das ja gemacht. Wir haben die Nameschlusskonferenz verworfen, wo viele erstmal einen Schreck bekommen haben. Wir haben das Format verändert. Viele haben einen Schreck bekommen. Und am Ende ist aber unser Fazit. Und ich kann eigentlich nur Armen sagen, zu dem, was du vorhin gesagt hast. Ich sehe es genauso. Wir sind inhaltlich besser aufgestellt. Die inhaltlichen Detailänderungen, wie der Coldopener, YouTube sowieso, hat alles dem Produkt Rasenfunk wahnsinnig gut getan. Und am Ende können wir, glaube ich, es auch so sehen. Wir waren nicht ganz so skeptisch. Wir waren eigentlich sehr positiv. Aber es ist eben schön zu lesen, dass diejenigen oder jemand in dem Fall, der am Anfang skeptisch war, das jetzt alles ganz toll finden und sich gar nicht mehr anders vorstellen kann. Das ist eigentlich das schönste Kompliment für diesen Weg.
Und dazu muss man sagen, also bei dem ging es jetzt eben darum, um die Schwerpunkt-Aufteilung, also raus aus der Spieltagssendung. Übrigens hat es die Schwerpunkte viel besser gemacht. Sie sind länger geworden. In der Regel haben sie noch mal eine ganz andere Gesprächsatmosphäre. Und dazu muss man aber auch sagen, uns ist auch sehr bewusst, also das soll jetzt hier nicht wie Beklagen über die Situation ankommen, weil das ist ja alles von uns selber produziert. Wir haben uns selber quasi dazu entschieden, auch dieses Pensum zu machen. Wir wussten auch, was da auf uns zukommt. Aber wir müssen jetzt feststellen, dass es dann doch in der Art und Weise vielleicht nicht für immer funktioniert. Also nicht mit einem langfristigen Gedanken, weil sonst irgendwann die Qualität leidet. Und das ist eben der Punkt, der nicht passieren darf. Wir wollen immer auf einem gewissen Standard bleiben, weil wir glauben, dass das der Kern des Rasenfunks ist. Und daher kommen diese Überlegungen und daher kommt auch so mancher Gedanke. Und deswegen wird es auch erstmal kein Champions League-Format geben.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, um die Frage zu beantworten, ich glaube, das können wir ausschließen erstmal.
Ja, das wird tatsächlich nicht passieren. Aber deswegen glauben wir, dass es inhaltlich ganz gut ist aktuell. Aber auch da Hörerinnenbefragung, wir sind total gespannt, was ihr eigentlich denkt. Denn wir bekommen ja immer nur so ein loses Feedback und vor allem von den Vielhörern. Und mich würden die Nebenbeihörer auch ehrlicherweise mal sehr interessieren.
Und ich will noch mal ganz kurz so eine Schleife zurückmachen. Wir haben an irgendeinem Punkt heute darüber gesprochen, warum wir eigentlich immer wachsen wollen. Das ist hier relativ gut sichtbar. Wachsen heißt ja für uns auch ein Stück weit, was können wir machen, um neue Hörer zu erreichen? Und zum Teil ist die jetzige Formataufstellung ja auch eine, also es ist natürlich eine inhaltliche Überzeugung von uns, aber zum Teil ja auch eine Idee und diese Aufsplittungen in mehrere Feeds, eine Idee, Hörer besser gezielter anzusprechen, um sie besser zu erreichen und im Ergebnis natürlich mehr zu erreichen. Mehr Unterstützer zu gewinnen, hätte zur Folge, dass wir uns leichter tun würden, nicht unbedingt inhaltlich, weil das ist natürlich mit dem Anspruch, den wir haben, inhaltlich gar nicht so einfach, aber dass wir uns leichter tun würden, uns personell zu verstärken, um dann im Ergebnis wieder flexibler zu sein, was den Output angeht. Also, es hängt alles ein bisschen zusammen. Wir haben nicht Wachstum im Sinne, auch wenn Max es vorhin scherzhaft auf die Weltherrschaft gelingt hat, Wachstum des Wachstums will und weil wir gerne Millionäre werden, sondern einfach Wachstum, weil dann der Rasenfunk auf besseren, gesünderen Beinen stehen würde, weil es uns leichter fallen würde, andere Leute mit an Bord zu holen, die uns helfen, dieses Ziel, das wir mit dem Rasenfunk haben, umzusetzen. Insofern ist, glaube ich, die Frage damit ganz gut beantwortet. Würden wir ab sofort 20 Prozent mehr Einnahmen haben, würden wir uns wesentlich leichter tun, jemanden zusätzlich mit an Bord zu holen. Stattdessen kämpfen wir jetzt mit potenziellen weniger Einnahmen durch Kontoumstellungen. Aber das ist halt einfach der tägliche Business-Struggle dann am Ende.
Ja, und dazu muss man sagen, wir haben ja eine eingepreiste Inflation, nur die wirkt sich bei uns anders aus. Also wir müssen auch deshalb wachsen, weil wir ja auch immer wieder Supporterinnen verlieren. Also der normale Lebenszyklus eines Supporters oder einer Supporterin, der endet irgendwann, weil sich Lebensumstände verändern, finanzielle Situationen verändert, weil man auch vielleicht einfach keine Lust mehr hat, vielleicht auch inhaltlich nicht zufrieden ist. Wir wissen das ehrlicherweise nicht. Die melden sich sehr, sehr selten bei uns. Wenn sie sich melden, dann hat es inhaltlich eigentlich nie was zu tun. Dann wollen sie uns sagen, ich würde euch so gern unterstützen, aber ich kann nicht mehr oder ich interessiere mich einfach nicht mehr für den Fußball. Und das müssen wir auch auffangen. Also allein dafür bräuchten wir ein geringes Wachstum, immer um neue Leute finden zu können, die da nachwachsen. Damit sind wir schon wieder beim Geldthema gelandet. Wir haben vorhin schon einige Fragen von euch, die in Richtung Geld gingen, beantworten, was vor allem die Gästehonorare angeht. Und ich glaube, ihr könnt euch dadurch jetzt auch schon ganz gut zusammenreimen, dass natürlich unterschiedliche Formate unterschiedlich hohe Ausgaben haben. Wir versuchen das aber nicht so miteinander zu verrechnen. Aber es gibt noch einen ganz, ganz großen Punkt beim Geldthema, der uns auch sehr wichtig ist und der ehrlicherweise mir persönlich auch sehr schwer im Magen liegt. Deswegen habe ich da auch in dem Rasenfunk-Newsletter an alle Supporterinnen auch schon mal was zu geschrieben, nämlich die Frage nach der Transparenz. Warum findet man bei uns auf der Seite, also es ging ja quasi bis hin zu, man könnte es ja bis auf jeden Cent hin aufschlüsseln oder zumindest eine Tortengrafik, die sagt, so und so viel Prozent eures Geldes gehen an XY und so weiter. Vor allem, nachdem wir das ja in der letzten Sendung dieser Art schon mal aufgedröset haben. Also die Zahlen dazu, die Prozentzahlen, die prozentuale Verteilung, die gibt es und die sollte eigentlich dann auch auf der Webseite landen. Kleine Hintergrundgeschichte dazu. Es gab dann mal wieder eine Ausgabe, von der wir nicht wussten, dass wir die noch tätigen müssen als GmbH. Die muss noch eingerechnet werden. Und dann ist mir aufgefallen, dass bei den Prozentzahlen, die wir genannt haben, das hat im Großen zum Glück nichts verändert. Aber der Teil unbeachtet geblieben ist, dass wir natürlich auch ein bisschen was zurückgelegt haben, weil wir ja eben nicht irgendwie rein raus auf einer Null arbeiten wollen, so wie alle Bundesligisten, sondern uns ja eben darauf einrichten wollen, dass eben auch mal was zurückgeht. Oder zum Beispiel eine Kamera für YouTube gekauft werden muss, die euch vielleicht schon aufgefallen ist, liebe YouTube-Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer. Also das ist einer der Gründe, warum wir das nicht veröffentlicht haben. Und dann ist grundsätzlich Transparenz bei diesen Zahlen für mich zumindest ein wirklich schwieriges Thema. Und ich muss dazu ganz kurz ausholen. Es stellt sich ja wirklich die Frage, warum veröffentlichen wir nicht jede Zahl? Und ich persönlich möchte das deshalb nicht, wegen einem Prozent von euch. Oder wahrscheinlich ist es weniger. 0,15 Prozent von euch. Es gibt einen ganz, ganz, ganz verschwindend geringen Teil von Menschen da draußen, die uns und in dem Fall auch mir persönlich nichts Gutes wollen und die darauf warten, irgendetwas zum Vorwurf machen zu können. Aus den unterschiedlichsten Gründen und die das vielleicht auch gar nicht immer so merken, was sie tun. Also als Beispiel will ich einmal illustrieren. Ich habe ja sehr prominent im Rasenfunk nach einer neuen Bleibe für die Zwillinge und mich gesucht. Warum habe ich das gemacht? Weil wir keine Chance hatten, auf dem völlig kranken Münchner Wohnungsmarkt. Es ist kein leichter Schritt, mit so was in die Öffentlichkeit zu gehen. Und dann melden sich Leute und ich verstehe das, dass sie sich melden und sagen, ey, das gibt es ja nicht. Du willst mehr für eine Wohnung ausgeben, als ich netto im Monat verdiene. Und das schürt sehr viel Frust und Wut. Und das Ding ist, ich bin genauso wütend. Also was ich dann zurückgeschrieben habe, ist ja, und ich finde das für uns beide scheiße. Es ist falsch, dass ich so viel Geld allein für eine Wohnung zahlen soll im München. Und ich finde es genauso scheiße, dass du so wenig verdienst. Und es gibt dann aber auch Leute, die dann gewisse Grenzen überschreiten, die meiner Meinung nach nicht überschritten gehören. Also dann wird einem auch geraten, zieh du einfach an das Bundesland. Warum musst du überhaupt deine Kinder 50-50 betreuen? Also ihr könnt euch nicht vorstellen, wer sich da in welcher Art und Weise dann doch auch meldet. Und das halte ich aus. Und das führt aber dazu, dass ich, obwohl ich weiß, dass 99,9 Prozent von euch da draußen, wenn sie jetzt zum Beispiel unsere Geschäftsführergehälter sehen würden, dass die da gar nichts zuzusagen hätten und das einordnen können, den Kontext dazu kennen. Vielleicht auch den Unterschied kennen zwischen, zahlt man eine Wohnung und Lebenshaltungskosten in München oder woanders und uns das nicht missgönnen. Obwohl ich das weiß, möchte ich diese Zahlen dann doch nicht im Internet haben. Weil ich glaube, dass ich nicht mit den Nadelstichen, die durch einzelne E-Mails dann gerne anonym reinkommen, auf Dauer umgehen könnte, weil wir ja selber darunter leiden, wie unsere Welt ökonomisch so aufgebaut ist. Also Frank und ich, ich spreche jetzt wieder für dich, aber wir sind ja beide so, dass wir das nicht gut finden, wie ungleich Einkommen verteilt sind, wie schlecht bezahlt viele Berufe sind, die wirklich wichtig sind, wie überbezahlt dann wir vielleicht auch sind. Also im Vergleich dazu sind wir definitiv überbezahlt, weil unsere Arbeit ist nicht so wichtig. Und deswegen wird es, glaube ich, die volle Transparenz nie geben können, weil ich glaube, ich halte das nicht aus. Und das hat mir wirklich diese Wohnungsnummer auch nochmal gezeigt. Da gab es eklige Reaktionen, ganz, ganz wenige, aber es gab sie.
Ja, und du sprichst da völlig zurecht für mich, weil ich es im Grunde ganz genauso sehe. Wir haben uns ja auch vor dieser Wohnungssache schon darüber unterhalten und waren uns im Grunde einig. Dass wir Transparenz schaffen wollen, insofern, dass wir euch zeigen, wofür geben wir euer Geld aus, was aber eben nicht heißen kann, dass wir damit auf die einzelne Buchung zurückgehen oder euch, keine Ahnung, andere Summen nennen, die eben Raum bieten für solche Menschen und für solche Aktionen. Drum gehen wir eben ein bisschen bewusst damit um, wie wir es veröffentlichen, in welcher Form und in welchem Detailgrad. Wir hoffen und euer Feedback zeigt es im Grunde, dass das genug ist, dass ihr uns vertrauen könnt, dass wir damit nicht, ich glaube, ich habe sie irgendwo im Notizdokument gerade gelesen, nicht damit an die Börse gehen, zu spekulieren, wobei das tatsächlich noch einer der harmloseren Dinge ist, die ich mir jetzt vorstellen könnte, die man mit, wie man Geld voruntreuen kann oder, na ja, eben Schindluder damit treiben. Nein, wir investieren nicht in Krypto, auch nicht in Tesla-Aktien. Wir sind da relativ konservativ. Wir versuchen natürlich, Rücklagen zu bilden, aber um ehrlich zu sein und ohne da jetzt ins Detail zu gehen, so viel höher sind die Einnahmen nicht als die Ausgaben, dass diese Rücklagen riesig sein können. Wir operieren hier auch, wenn es eine GmbH ist, im Grunde mit relativ kleinen Summen. In erster Linie, ja, in erster Linie. Aber wir haben die, Max sagt es gerade, wir haben die die Verteilung beim letzten Mal veröffentlicht, da gegenüber hat sich seither nicht so massiv viel geändert. Wir planen es auf jeden Fall, auf der Website zu tun in Form von einem Kuchendiagramm, damit ihr seht, wo geht anteilig das Geld hin. Und ich glaube, es sind ja im Wesentlichen die Gästehonorare, die Gehälter und ein paar technische Ausgaben. Und dann war es das im Grunde. Also ist es alles nicht so fürchterlich komplex.
Na gut, und Steuern und Abgaben, Frank. Das ist der eine Punkt, der mit dazu gab. Ich könnte ja sagen, KSK-Abgabe für Gäste, die bei uns drin sind, hatten wir nicht auf dem Schirm, wussten wir nicht. Und müssen wir halt jetzt rückwirkend abführen.
Künstler-Sozialkanzler, für diejenigen, die nicht sofort wissen, worum es geht.
Gäste bei uns, die einen Honorar bekommen haben, deren Hauptschwerpunkt beruflich eine künstlerische Tätigkeit ist oder eine publizistische Tätigkeit, da müssen wir einfach noch mal zusätzlich, inzwischen sind es 5 Prozent, vorher waren es 4,5 Prozent des Netto-Betrags, an die KSK überweisen.
So viel übrigens auch zu Folgen der Erhöhung der Gästehonorare.
Ja, genau, das mussten wir auch damit reinrechnen. Also es war gar nicht so trivial. Zum Glück hast du da diese tolle Taschenrechner-App, mit der du das alles gemacht hast. Und mit Taschenrechner-App war es schon eine Beleidigung der App. Aber das zum Beispiel ist mit draufgekommen, nachdem wir die Zahlen genannt hatten, weil wir uns dessen einfach nicht bewusst waren. Das war ein Fehler unsererseits. Und dann haben sich aber die Zahlen wieder verändert und wir wussten aber auch gleich noch gar nicht, wie viel das sein würde. Also ich musste dann für jedes Gästehonorar seit 2018 eine Zuweisung durchführen. Ist das jetzt jemand, der sonst einen Hauptjob hat, der eine andere Tätigkeit ist oder der eben darunter fällt und musste das für jedes einzelne Honorar machen? Das haben wir der KSK gemeldet und dann dauert sowas ja so ewig. Also wir haben jetzt für das für 2023, glaube ich, haben wir jetzt den Betrag, den für 2024 haben wir gemeldet und quasi das passt. Und ab jetzt zahlen wir voraus. Das heißt, es ist nicht mehr so ein ewiges Hin und Her. Aber die alten Sachen, da habe ich, glaube ich, immer noch keine Rückmeldung bekommen. Ich bin mir sogar sicher, dass ich nur keine bekommen habe. Also das kam auch mit rein. Und das sind dann halt auch ein paar Tausend Euro. Und dann verändern sich die Prozente zahlen dann doch wieder. Aber es liegt uns auch schwer im Magen. Wir wollen transparenter sein. Die volle Transparenz wird es aus den genannten Gründen allerdings nicht geben können. Und einen Punkt kann ich dann vielleicht aus den Hinterkulissen und privaten Fragen dann da noch mit dazu ziehen. Ich denke, ihr habt das gemerkt. Ich hoffe, ihr habt es dem Produkt Rasenfunk nicht angemerkt. Aber ich spreche jetzt mal für mich und du kannst sagen, was du willst für dich, Frank. Aber das zweite Halbjahr im letzten Jahr waren die krassesten Monate, die ich vielleicht seit mindestens zehn Jahren erlebt habe. Das war von der Belastung her in sämtlichen Lebensbereichen ultra hart. Wirklich ultra. Und in dieser Situation war ich gottfroh, irgendwie den Betrieb im Rasenfunk aufrechterhalten zu können. Und dass man das nicht allzu doll merkt, könnte man bei YouTube gucken, an welchen Orten ich alles Sendung gemacht habe. Das gibt schon mal so einen kleinen Hinweis darauf, wie das alles war. Und da war dann an solche Themen leider gar nicht mehr zu denken. Also das muss ich auch tatsächlich sagen. Das ist dann natürlich auch schlecht und nicht gut, dass wir dann ausgerechnet mit der Transparenz auf der Webseite und wie wir das jetzt eigentlich darstellen wollen, nicht weiterkommen. Aber da lagen ganz, ganz viele andere Dinge auch noch brach. So war es im letzten Jahr bei mir und es ist auch noch nicht komplett wieder entspannt. Das wäre jetzt auch eine Lüge, das zu behaupten.
Wir müssen da auch, glaube ich, insgesamt einfach sagen, eure Nachfragen dazu sind alle völlig berechtigt. Keiner ist damit böse oder irgendwas in irgendeiner Form. Aber aus unserer Sicht müssen wir einfach auch sagen, diese Dinge können wir auch neben dem Normalbetrieb, was ja im Rasenfunk immer noch der Podcast ist und die Produktion immer nur dann machen, wenn dafür Zeit ist. Und das ist ganz wichtig und gerade jetzt, wie Max geschildert hat, wenn so eine Stressphase im Leben, im Job, was auch immer ist, solche Dinge dauern dann halt einfach ein bisschen und ihr müsst da einfach uns vertrauen, dass wir trotzdem keinen Unsinn machen und dass diese Dinge trotzdem irgendwann kommen, auch wenn sie ein bisschen länger dauern, weil es eben, ja, es soll gar nicht negativ oder abwertend klingen, aber es sind zweitrangige Dinge. Vorrangig ist da eben der Betrieb des Podcasts und die Produktion der Inhalte.
Gebt uns auch dazu gerne Feedback. Reicht euch das? Oder ist das vielleicht auch ein Grund, warum ihr nicht supportet oder nicht mehr supportet? Das wäre natürlich auch sehr wichtig zu wissen. Aber gut, die Hörerinnenbefragung. Wie oft habe ich es jetzt heute? Das wäre ein gutes Trinkspiel gewesen für diese Sendung. Na ja, vielleicht treffe ich es noch in die Show Notes.
Vielleicht gut. Es ist Vormittag.
Für uns ist Vormittag. Wann das hier veröffentlicht wird, weiß ich gerade tatsächlich nicht.
So viel zum Blick hinter die Kulissen. Es ist Vormittag.
Ja, aber nur auf ganz knapp Vormittag muss man sagen.
Es ist auch die Überschrift des nächsten Absatzes im Notizdokument.
Okay, du bist bei einem anderen Absatz als ich.
Ich bin schon zu weit gerutscht.
Ja, aber wirklich. Also, manche Fragen werden wir jetzt nicht beantworten. Es gab viele private Fragen. Es gab auch so Fragen zu sportlichen Themen, wie ich zum Mann gegen Mann-Pressing und so weiter stehe. Das passt jetzt leider nicht mehr hier rein. Zeitlich gesehen, weil wir auflaufen.
Solche Themen passen übrigens immer besser ins Forum. Um nochmal darauf hinzuweisen, bitte auch keine Mails schreiben. Das ist wirklich lieb. Aber solche, wenn da manchmal so ein Brett und E-Mail kommen, dann denkt man sich wahnsinnig geil, wie jemand wirklich Zeit investiert hat, um da tiefgründig einzusteigen. Aber in den meisten Fällen ist es wirklich schwer, da inhaltlich darauf einzugehen. Wenn ihr das ins Forum schreibt, erlebt ihr eine viel vitalere Diskussion dazu. Und Max und ich haben trotzdem die Gelegenheit, damit einzusteigen, wenn es passt.
Und gerade die lange und ausführlich formulierten Mails, die bleiben leider bei mir manchmal liegen, weil ich möchte dann mit einem ähnlichen Aufwand antworten und kriege den dann nicht gestemmt. Also ich möchte beschämte Grüße an den Hörer und Supporter schicken, der mir einen Zeitartikel zur ökonomischen Situation unter anderem in Leipzig geschickt hat im Sommer. Dazu eine sehr lange E-Mail. Ich trage diese E-Mail immer noch im Kopf mit mir herum, weil ich auf sie antworten will und kriege es aber einfach nicht hin. Und inzwischen kann man sich wirklich einfach nur dafür schämen. Aber so ist es eben leider. Ihr habt viele Fragen zu hinter den Kulissen und sportlichen Einschätzungen, und so weiter, gefragt. Ich würde jetzt aber noch mal die rauspicken, die tatsächlich auch für den Ablauf des Rasenfunks relevant sind. Und da gibt es vor allem drei Personen, nach denen ihr quasi indirekt gefragt habt. Nämlich, was hat sich verändert dadurch, dass wir mit Moritz jetzt jemanden haben, der uns beim Guested-Management hilft? Und was hat sich dadurch verändert, dass wir mit Marc und Eva ein Moderatorinnen-Duo haben, das die zweite Liga übernommen hat? Ich beginne mal mit Moritz. Es ist ein Segen. Er ist ein Segen. Es ist das, was wir erhofft haben. Es ist ein bisschen ernüchternd zu sehen, obwohl mir so viel jetzt abgenommen wird durch Moritz. Das Guested-Management, es war die Hölle, ich sage es einfach wie es ist. Das hat an manchen Tagen 70 Prozent des Tages angenommen. Man mag es gar nicht glauben. Obwohl so viel besser geworden ist, bin ich immer noch voll ausgelastet. Ich hätte es mir ein bisschen anders gewünscht, aber das heißt nicht, dass er nicht eine riesengroße Hilfe ist. Die ist er und es ist eine ganz große Entlastung. Vor allem auch viele administrative Dinge nicht mehr im Kopf behalten zu müssen. Es ist auch wie Mental Load, der mir abgenommen wird. Also ich weiß jetzt eben zum Beispiel bei Neulingen im Podcast, die bekommen den mitwirkenden Vertrag zugeschickt und da wird auch nachgehackt, dass sie ihn bitte unterschreiben und zurückschicken. Und ja, hast du dein Kreuz gemacht bei Umsatzsteuer? Ja oder nein? Ach, du brauchst noch Beratung dazu. Okay, das hier wären Möglichkeiten. Und hast du uns schon ein Foto fürs Thumbnail geschickt und so weiter und so fort? Das, Moritz, das macht, ist eine riesengroße Entlastung. Und es hilft total und hat sich, also hat genau den Effekt gebracht, den wir uns erhofft haben und noch viel mehr, weil Moritz ja selbst jetzt zu so einer Figur im Rasenfunkkosmos geworden ist, allein durch das Glückwunschvideo zu den zehn Jahresgeburtstag. Also es ist eine große Erleichterung und es ist auch toll, dass ihr das mit eurer Unterstützung möglich gemacht habt. Denn auch da war das ja erst mal ein finanzielles, ja doch ein kleines Risiko war es schon, das jetzt einfach zu machen, weil wir jetzt nicht irgendwie Moritz mit reinholen wollten und dann nach zwei Monaten wieder sagen wollten, okay, gut, das klappt jetzt doch nicht, sorry, du bist raus. Dafür war der Onboarding-Prozess schon allein zu lang. Aber ja, es ist eine große Entlastung und es ist super und hebt den Rasenfunk auf eine nächste Stufe. Und dann haben wir noch Mark und Eva als Moderatorinnen der Zweitligasendungen. Also ja, ich höre jede Sendung und ich bin auch sehr begeistert, wie gut das funktioniert. Und inzwischen ist auch der Schmerz nicht mehr immer da, dass ich die Sendung nicht moderieren darf, denn das ist natürlich das Dove bei so einem Typen, der immer alles selber machen will, dass er dann auch wirklich Schmerzen empfindet, wenn er jetzt nicht über den HSV und Schalke sprechen will, obwohl diejenigen, die es tun, besser vorbereitet sind, als er es geschafft hätte. Also ich finde das ganz toll, wie Eva und Mark das machen. Ich habe auch den Eindruck, dass es euch so geht, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Wenn dem so ist, dann lasst ihn mal ein bisschen Liebe da in den Kommentaren auf allen möglichen Plattformen. Ihr wisst ja, wie ihr sie findet und im Forum schauen sie ja auch definitiv rein. Also das funktioniert sehr gut. Es ist inhaltlich. So, wie wir uns das vorstellen. Sie stehen vor denselben technischen Hürden, die wir manchmal auch haben. Du hast manchmal einfach eine Sendung, da funktioniert das Internet beim Gast nicht. Das tröstet auch ein bisschen, ehrlich gesagt. Und vor allem, dass ich dann auch sagen kann, es ist völlig normal. Denkt euch nichts. Manchmal klappt es einfach nicht. Aber das funktioniert gut. Und weil die Frage von Schorsch dann noch kam, inwiefern sie redaktionell eingebunden sind, also eben für die zweite Liga entscheiden Mark und Eva, wie sie es machen wollen. Und ich gebe da manchmal meinen Senf zu ab. Gefragt, sehr selten auch ungefragt. Ich hoffe aber immer so, dass es für beide passt. Ansonsten meldet ihr euch mal bei mir über die entsprechenden Kanäle. Das planen alles komplett Eva und Mark gemeinsam mit Moritz. Und ihr merkt ja, wie gut das Ergebnis ist. Also das ist alles ganz wunderbar. Aber das ist derzeit auch so ihr Betätigungsfeld. Also die Schwerpunktplanung jetzt, ich weiß nicht, ob das eben damit gemeint war. Die von den Männervereinen, die mache noch ich, weil das ja auch so ein bisschen korrespondiert mit mit den Spieltagssendungen und so weiter und so fort. Also wir sind sehr, sehr happy.
Absolut, ja, kann ich nur bestätigen.
Ich glaube, Frank, damit haben wir das Gro der Fragen tatsächlich geschafft.
Sieht so aus, ja, ich kann zumindest auch beim Durchscrollen nichts mehr finden, was wir jetzt nicht zumindest so entfernt abgedeckt haben, bis auf die eher privaten Dinge.
Da gibt es ehrlicherweise auch bei den privaten Dingen gibt es auch Fragen, die sich immer wieder wiederholen. Also wenn ihr jetzt das hier die erste Q&A-Folge ist, die ihr hört, dann hört doch mal in die vom letzten Jahr rein und die vom vorletzten Jahr. Da gibt es ja Kapitelmarken und so weiter und so fort. Ich bin mir sehr sicher, dass einige Fragen, die jetzt unbeantwortet geblieben sind, oder ich weiß es sogar, die haben wir schon relativ oft beantwortet und da hat sich dann auch nichts wirklich dran verändert. Und die Details zum neuen Rasenfunk-Headquarter, stimmt, das war noch eine Frage, die Last Minute reinkam. Ja, Internet-Download und Upload ist noch ein Thema, aber wir sind dran. Sowohl ich persönlich als auch die GmbH. Mal gucken, was sich da verändert. Aber inzwischen haben wir einen Modus, der zumindest ein halbwegs wie Wendy ist. Also es geht halbwegs aktuell und wird hoffentlich noch besser werden. Wir sind halt in Deutschland.
Und insgesamt sei gesagt, ihr könnt eure Fragen auch immer und jederzeit im Forum stellen. Also es gibt keinen Grund, da immer auf eine Q&A-Sendung zu warten. Vor allem, wenn es um so Dinge geht wie Max NFL vorlieben oder sowas. Das sind dann oft Sachen, die hier sowieso nicht so ganz gut reinpassen.
Hallo. Ich würde sagen, oder ihr hört halt einfach mal die Super Bowl Folgen, die es in dem Jahr gibt.
Oder die Super Bowl Folgen.
Also ich mache ja keinen Hilf auf.
Ich wollte sagen als Alternative. Ja, genau. Ja, also nutzt gerne und mehr das Forum. Das ist unsere liebste Plattform für Nachrichten an uns direkt oder Fragen über den Rasenfunk, Diskussionen über den Fußball oder auch über das Laravel Backend rasenfunk.de gerne, gerne dort. Da finden sich in der Regel immer andere verrückte Hörer, die in irgendeiner Form da auch mit zu tun haben. Und da habt ihr eine schöne Community und und wir freuen uns drüber.
Und fürs tägliche den C in die Community, in den Community Tümpel reinhalten, sei der Discord empfohlen. Wenn ihr einfach mal so ein bisschen wissen wollt, wie die Leute so ticken, die den Rasenfunk hören oder manche Leute ticken, dann sei euch unser inoffizieller Discord-Server auch nochmal ans Herz gelegt. Da kriegt man, glaube ich, einen ganz guten Eindruck.
Den muss der Max jetzt aber auch in die Show Notes packen.
Ja, ja, ich habe mir hier schon Notiz gemacht. Das frage ich mich immer, ob das den YouTube-Hörern eigentlich auch fällt, was ich hier die ganze Zeit neben den Sendungen noch mache, mit meinen Kapitelmarken und mit dem Stummschalten. Und manchmal editiere ich schon live in der Sendung, wenn ich weiß, es wird mit der Produktion ein bisschen eng, oder hier mit meinen Notizen. Naja, bisher hat sich noch nie jemand dazu geäußert. Wir sollten aber noch ein paar SupporterInnen danken, oder soll ich das noch machen, Frank? Was meinst du?
Ja, mach mal, auf jeden Fall.
Dann danken wir in dieser Sendung Benéo, Superunioner, Bell vom Brentano Bart, wo ich irgendwie das Gefühl habe, wir kennen diese Bell. Herzliche Grüße, Katrin, Tim aus der Schweiz und dem ersten FC 03. Ganz herzlichen Dank für eure Unterstützung. Und wenn ihr das noch nicht wisst, wie man uns unterstützt, dann solltet ihr jetzt wirklich auf rasenfunk.de gehen, denn es geht in jeder möglichen Form. Und letztlich haben auch alle diejenigen, die jetzt Fragen gestellt haben, diese Folge hier unterstützt. Ganz herzlichen Dank dafür. Danke für euer Vertrauen und für eure Geduld mit euch. Auch diese Sendung ist ja jetzt leider später rausgekommen, als wir es geplant hatten. Wir sind sehr gespannt auf euer Feedback. Wir sind sehr gespannt auf eure Antworten in der Hörerinnenbefragung. Wir wünschen euch, dass ihr gesund bleibt und dass ihr uns gewogen bleibt. Bis bald, bald, ciao!
Danke, servus!
Das war der Rasenfunk. Wir grüßen alle, die uns liebhaben.